what up pimp and welcome to another
episode of the h3 podcast alive catch it
every Friday at 3:00 p.m. at twitch.tv
4/8 reproductions here to date with eel
of course but as importantly here with
Eric common etiquette what up ping
thanks for coming and Jack hello hello
Oh Jack's film hello to wonderful
youtubers who I admire very much and I'm
super super excited to have here with us
we've got cigarettes on deck I'm not a
smoker but when people bring cigarettes
I sometimes some of them kids don't
smoke it's horrible have it we've got
some Rose day
compliments of Eric sparkling rose a
sparkling rose Arafat see where the fell
okay so anyway thank you guys for coming
really excited yeah let's just actually
almost I mean really I realize there you
should probably fill more because I'll
just keep going here don't go hard yeah
everybody get a little bit more than one
more to the UH to the emoji movie oh
thank you you're the emoji July 28th 7
days guys absolutely Cheers plancha
salud
luck I am all of them school there it is
so how are you guys doing what's going
on what's good baby
ah too much man just uh you know I'm
struggling to stay relevant on all the
all the social medias not eternal
struggle the eternal you know you always
have that that fear in the back of your
head like Oh a Scottie one's gonna
happen when am I just when are people
just going to turn off you know when but
the thing that bothers me about that
question I don't do it do you feel that
yeah oh yeah cuz like well you've been
around for a while too
you got wool you're you're like them
actually yeah you guys have books in
around forever
I think the first youtube video ever put
up was in 2007
yeah before that there was like I think
you could only make a video like 5
minutes long right there are times
earlier yo so that's the thing attrition
me out about you is that you're the
salvia guy I'm always in the shadows but
like because you were a meme you were
like one of the original internet memes
yeah I'm the deep state of YouTube
you're your teacher the dark web yeah
I'm on behind the scenes so like Joey
salads all those guys all comes back to
me if you follow the money money at all
these back to Eric but he would if you
guys probably seen this smoking salvia
meme
and when I met you and I started
watching your videos became a fan it
didn't click right away that you're that
guy and I was like what the [ __ ] I look
a lot different
I'm not a young man and I feel that I
feel that well it's also a big departure
to I mean you have the salvia vids but
then you're this total 180 with the
comment etiquette no there's no relation
I don't really play for girag
you should anybody during that's right
so this is common etiquette is your your
body on alcohol and it previously is
your body on salvia I'm doing I'm doing
a real trippy like human experiments
using that walking how's it going good
I shouldn't pause this area it's going
good I believe that see my doctor but I
am fascinated by this eternal struggle
to stay relevant on YouTube because I
feel that all the time yeah and the
thing that drives me crazy is that I
never know if it's my fans that don't
like me anymore or if it's YouTube's
algorithms yeah doesn't like me anymore
that's the thing that drives me [ __ ]
crazy
it's impossible to keep up what honestly
I can't keep up with the algorithm
anymore I just tried to make stuff when
I can as frequently as possible yeah you
know that's just and like it because if
you obsess about the the algorithm and
the numbers you will never live in it
you will absolutely go insane so I just
don't that movie where the guy starts
seeing like circles everywhere then
they're an auskey movie about pie oh
wait hi pop hi yeah yes the one with the
Jim Carrey no it's the number 23 oh yeah
that yeah that movie hilarious you can
just kill there one of the best carry
okay you put some mask on and
everything's green I love and I love the
double feature that movie with the emoji
movie possible I mean nothing stopping
you man ah well I excited I know the
deeper I get into YouTube the more I
found out like some really disturbing
[ __ ] from like some people high up on
YouTube that I honestly can't even say
but they're arcs I can say that they
there's an invisible hand pushing
content and suppressing content I can
say that that's the thing that happens
on YouTube
I believe it basically what admit it
they will never admit of course of
course
but I think anyone who's been on YouTube
for a long time yeah I agree
you know I'm getting slimed out of here
absolutely it's just all about I mean
like art so you've been around since
seven oh six it's just all about like
how can you like how can you adapt
obviously I know it's cliche but it's
all about adapting is changing and it's
making sure that you don't lose your
personality in your style but you mold
it to contemporary trends what I want to
say trends but you have to mold it to
the tastes and the formats of today
because videos today are way different
than what they were five seven ten years
ago yeah I've noticed that your contents
changed a lot over the years I sure have
is that is that a conscious effort to
like switch with the with what you think
works on YouTube well it's it's it's a
and B a lot of it is yeah merely trying
to catch up but a lot of it is also like
what I think is funny is so what I think
is funny today isn't necessarily what I
thought was funny ten years ago I mean
like who here hasn't you looked at their
own content from years ago and cringed
and winsome that's not funny
visible right you know you'd see that
look and go well I would do that
differently yeah that's how I feel you
know and I get every single I've been
getting this since 2008 nine I missed
the ocean
I was in automating a Tele a cell phone
my patience for you
yeah because that's that's I guess
that's something that any youtuber gets
everything they want free for a couple
years a question is how long you get it
on an old timer so I can get it forever
yeah you're really smart about when
you're doing the daily videos the IE
yeah I don't do this daily anymore no no
I can't because if I do that daily then
I can't do anything else if I can't do
anything else then I create I do not
comprehend how much [ __ ] time that
must take it was joking all of it is
just in the editing you know it's just a
tedious chore to edit because it's all
like timing timing timing timing timing
you know it's not it's like you're
clipping frames you know frames to make
the joke work you know you think a joke
that maybe at 50 and with the timing you
can turn up to an 80 or 90 but it's all
about just the editing so that that was
the hardest part but the rest of it
wasn't that difficult it was just just
the being consistent about it which I
suck at generally there was a window
where I was I was okay yet and then
comedians aren't known for their
punctuality they're not they're not a
meant that I like to sleep in and do
whatever the hell they want for a week
or something to do right oh yeah
deadlines yeah yeah 72 years ago
speaking of which how long's it been
since I got a haircut I don't know I
just don't have the will to cut it so
what does our times think you I like
nice make an appointment that's it I'm
there I made like I get it
that's right it's going to take like two
hours of my day I could be playing video
games I could be napping I'm walking
you're saying you get it but it looks
like you have a pretty good clean cut
there Jackson ah man I don't know then
you get my own okay good yeah [ __ ] it
what you know I mean he's got a guy that
comes over wakes them up I'd be here
connecting royalty over here that's
right that's what I am Eric YouTube
loyal good yeah I'm the guy who cuts it
so I should it's really good money it's
kids way better than my clicks per
minute or whatever called your Adsense
today is well giving it up Erica yeah
can we get a beautiful tight shot of oh
no it's kind of God kind of gone sorry
era it's like salt and pepper now how
long ago was you got 19 months like
extremely that thing really fell apart I
know yeah yeah I can't even spike it up
anymore because you gotta maintain
Ludacris oh you got to maintain maybe
that's a high Oh Nathan aside and like
it's all brown on the bottom now Dan can
you can you pull up a picture of his
original pineapple cut yeah I think just
to get over for and after Google like
Eric pineapple boy on the pineapple boy
I'm up it's the worst superhero in the
DC Universe yeah yeah I know what only
had a couple of issues before they
pulled it he was easy so what was that
saga if for the people who don't know oh
I made a Kickstarter that was intended
as a joke but like fingers crossed it
would actually work where I asked for
some like 2 grand or something like that
just to drink wine and get a haircut I
never that was a wonderful team at I was
team and it took off if it ended up
doing really well and I think that's
where I realize like oh this is what
Kickstarter's for stupid [ __ ]
only honest kitchen butter I've seen
because every Kickstarter I think you
said in the video you're like it's all
most of its fraud all of its fraud every
paper harder is fraud pretty much you're
the only honest guy was like gimme money
I'm gonna get a [ __ ] haircut and
drink beer that was refreshing why it
was there why I who got sorry oh yeah I
don't want be run big wait wait wait
hold on hold on camera hold on did you
write that in the description do people
know you're going to be spending money
on beer because that is a little bit
better surprise oh that is fraud they're
all frauds come on don't include that in
this alright yo can we cut that out I
have got I've got lawyers chopping at
the bit
can we get on the kicks on the class
action oh wait now can we see what dents
and then are you pulling some up cause I
don't see [ __ ] pineapple boy Li let you
do it alone
you need to switch a danzig is your own
computer alright this was like this
there Eric Eric Eric I'm a pineapple I'm
a pineapple let's see if that was
anything else thumbnail for it oh wait
well I'll tell you well that's the
inspiration yeah yeah that one's [ __ ]
yo that one's that one thing we aim
that's what Jenna used as the basis [ __ ]
let me find your pineapple boy you
should just on that video hang in the
top right that go wait yeah the top yeah
that's what it was
wait was it there yeah there was a good
like on top I wouldn't that job yeah
that one a couple piece what did you
make this pineapple summary oh I think
this is from my subreddit oh nice there
it is surprisingly difficult to hold you
should just up in the video they like
they like to put up desktop backgrounds
and see what have you my subreddit pains
me all right it's all it's my entire
summer it is like you don't think like
Jax lost oh like every [ __ ] day do
you know what dude you're not the only
one I everybody subreddit is lit just
like in Compton Civil War yes and it
drives me [ __ ] crazy
oh I've been trying to stoke the flames
in mine you're like yeah what it is have
you stoked it um what do you do just
making alternate accounts and posting
obscene races
you know we're getting out of I find
like our on your level where is the
animus oh by the way I forgot to say so
I'm so a little late but this is owed is
sponsored by Mia STIs and audible more
on that later that was supposed to go in
the very beginning can we go back in
time
please pay out so we could just say a
bunch of really nice things about them
really oh yeah no I'm gonna do it
inaudible every day I'm gonna read you
them out
okay wait not yet let us save it save it
I'm gonna give him a full reach-around
though where is the band yes one with
the fertile text there and with Heather
you okay the long-awaited yeah so Lou
years in the Mesa that's a lot of hair
man when they do investing on my head
it's another dog yeah it looked like
it's all yeah that man was really
impulsive
yeah that's what it is it's not good hey
you got a new trim oh yeah there it is
how does perfect oh that's a perfect
shot the bench uh yeah UVI affordable
the types here in the back is really
something that's a that's a the tiniest
wall climbing wall everything my
expertise as tall as that wall climbing
thank you I think you just hang on it
and wait till your arms get tired a
beginner's guide yeah while climbing
this is how I got it grasp right pegs
that come out of the wall so how much
did you pay for that haircut this
haircut was you okay well what did you
raise for Kickstarter every but it was
yeah the the haircut was chosen by one
particular pleasure
he gave him six hundred six hundred
dollars doctor I was nearly all of that
know nearly all of that no she should be
arrested for fraud it was six honey here
there's a lot of materials that went
into this they're really expensive okay
and I'll turn it easy what's that if you
feel that you were fairly treated oh
yeah no I got a deal agile hipper
uh I gave her a wine after hey I like
six bottles of wine and I drink one she
was like these are rest of these are
yours I'll see you you just left it yeah
that was which left the wine there she
was so cool about the whole thing though
yeah
striking up a whole conversation pletely
happy with my own camera how was that's
cute I don't feel like nice about it
it's almost worth the 600 she did I was
telling Healy she did like a like a test
run on a dummy head Oh like oh so that's
right nice was a lot of hair on it until
you haircut she like back down there was
let ground earth it was like perfect she
like had the thing jeez she's good she's
working it like the all the stuff we
were just looking at on Google Images
yeah I was like okay how do I add a
little bit of that is what giant and she
left this little sluice in the front
Jenna
Locke Jenna law ello song shout out for
the pineapple Claire's Bobby oh go to
here and get your own for $600 for
Instagram Johnson some like close-up
pictures of it she took some like oh
cool we don't have to keep going on
about this well I heard your question oh
yeah like how many subscribers are you
it airs you're on 333 Milly I guess
going back to the YouTube thing like you
your channels seems to be like
criminally underrated alright not
underrated but under view could be able
love your content always see it on
reddit oh yeah it's always recommended
to me the algorithm seems to love
because it's always on my home page and
oh how do i but I don't know why why do
you think your cello has been so so so
bad at putting stuff up I think a
frequency yeah this could be a month
where I just put one video up and a lot
of that is like I'm I'm not used to
being self-employed for this long period
of time like I think all of us when
things started actually work you may
like oh I could just sit around and
drink and play Beatles 100 all day yeah
why not
and I think I have the opposite problem
where it's like I'm self-employed so
nobody sits two hours and I think of it
I end up working too much yeah I don't
worry on my free time yeah well I think
it shows I mean like you know you guys
exploded like how many subscribers did
you guys have before I feel like you
guys blew up like right around the time
when you were leaving your multi-channel
network that's right some people don't
belittle your ends
yeah yeah fullscreen and collective did
you guys ever have experience with
collective or fullscreen no no I'm with
full screen now and I've never I'd you
know which is had an issue with them yet
was a copyright thing it wasn't like was
it
anyway yeah it was being stupid on you
that happened that was like two years
ago I go oh there's our first debt
dominated reddit and I'd like already
the first time that we had anything like
that I quote yeah what is happening I
say that was it was a huge piece of the
puzzle being on reddit well got any
people people listening who don't know
who Erica's go to his general internet
comment Erica and give me [ __ ] a watch
because he is probably one of the most
under watched per quality of content
there hopefully I won't have that as a
award for long most underrated channel
and use your belly laugh every damn time
and asking at that tattoo covered up
though
yes this video was really good then this
was a this was a lot of fun just looking
at that hair I can't believe how much
it's grown out it's just anything she
cut like grids are gone when it first
started coming in there's like a little
bit of brown it was like like had more
definition to it almost looked more
pineappley oh cool what do you do now
because now you just look kind of like a
school shooter yeah yeah your face and
you're showing up at your one time
shooting up a theater it like I look
like a toucan
I would like I should be giving
nutrition effects on it I'm like a
another Kickstarter you start up in
other well I maintain it yeah that's all
it is a long-term care coordinator yeah
yeah OPH oh my god Eric's hair patreon
this is a Molly this requires monthly
upkeep oh yeah and a timer for the
current patreon I have I have to do
those with a bald cap on because the
hair has got its own layer I don't want
across the screen oh my god
I got ten on that our not donated on
patreon oh no hair I'm Andrea okay yeah
I mean you're getting something there
right it's my favorite content I mean
recently appears anyway so we can get
more hair videos oh yeah yeah yeah tell
me what's your what is the obsession
with the emoji movie because anyone
who's been following you knows that
you've been slamming the emoji movie or
what how long has it been
we are counting down as it been seven
months even jacking their [ __ ] and it's
about the frequency you know shows but I
feel like we can date the stupid meme of
mine back to either late last year or
early this year basically that's when
you heard you saw the trailer well yeah
they had like a teaser teaser
that was just like infamous it really
was one of most disliked videos on
YouTube for its time but then an actual
trailer didn't come out till May and
that's kind of unheard of for a for a
July movie or for any movie really no
trailers until two months before it
comes out was very weird but that once
the trailer came out seven later you
already you know that kind of kick
started the whole meme of it really back
in May because that's when I did like a
frame-by-frame analysis of right right
which was like an hour long because I'm
pausing it just analyzing everything I
know there hasn't seen very you know
observing the frame and can you
summarize your yeah it'll take analysis
it'll take an hour but um yeah
summarized no you have to see the full
things together and it's a feeling you
can brush can't rush art not even my dad
was like yeah I think I watched about 10
minutes before I signed up and oh my god
that's impressive what was the average
was someone that god I wish I knew I
didn't even bother to check you know I
just put it out there and let the world
do what it wanted algorithm turned on
you on that thank you
oh well I hope so I don't want anyone
watching the whole thing yeah tell me
what what is it that fascinates you
about the emoji movie and the movie
about emojis
yes exactly just like that Junaid amber
I am the expert here and here's my
breakdown no I just it's one of those
like I like many others I couldn't
believe that a major studio the film
studio was putting a big you know the
huge amount of money do you know what's
the budget on a film preps it's got to
be 100 milli hundreds of million yet at
least a hundred and it's just the fact
that it exists at all fascinates me look
back gently they these just imagine like
these these these these middle-aged you
know fat cats just decided all right
what let's tap into the psyche of Young
America
what is what they want to do what is why
moat Mia my granddaughter she's always
texting and emojis done good log it
right it will get TJ Miller will get a
famous real actor and who was Sir
Patrick Stewart yeah we were talking
about that before we started but the
fact they got a night
to voice the poop emoji I understand
therapy rides the same time he's close
to death do we really want this piece of
work you know he just recorded that like
in [ __ ] car like is in traffic on the
way a lot of us that do like Shakespeare
on the park - yes that was item I guess
is jean-luc Picard here this man has a
legacy I didn't know not actually that
it will be the pooping buck a lot I
learned it the thing that fascinate me
is like this movie is just
representative all the formulated
garbage they're churning out it's like
the emot-- the poop emoji wants to be a
[ __ ] muscle emoji as you think west
because they said you have to be a poop
emoji knees like nah Doug no no no no
girl power no gene this is your plot the
plot actually is that jeans was a mess
emoji yeah what man you know yeah you
know I say weird cuz CJ Miller has that
voice I'm I can't do it my buddy Brock
this is such a better TJ Miller
impression anyway he's the voice car
he's the voice guy he was amazing
um but so gene is a mess emoji but he's
good the conflict the central conflict
of the films that he feels all these
other emotions emotions if you will and
his parents don't want to feel that
because his parents which were also a
mess emojis they say son you have one
job and that job is to go mad whenever
playing the second block he's not yeah
he's not supposed to yeah cuz like good
in collar bone it's a story of
empowerment it's just um really arm and
finding your own identity they spread it
yourself people want you to be a man but
you're gonna be a yes a party hat poppin
emoji right or what have you wonder if
the executives had notes on that and
they're like you know we make a lot of
money off these emojis do we really want
to we really want them thinking for
themselves right reg I like really
metaphysically or we get negative on the
emojis bad PR for the emojis or we make
it all look kind of thinking oh geez are
impenetrable to bad PR TJ Miller really
fought to maybe that he was an integrity
he did absolutely that's why you left
Silicon Valley so that he could
negotiate the scripts better too much on
delay
yeah
she led the that's right well here's the
thing that kills me you know that movie
is kind of kill it I'm gonna kill it oh
it's gonna make a fuckload of money and
there's no such thing as bad press for a
film people are like you know [ __ ]
on it obviously meaning about it for
half a year it's going to just destroy
the box-office and that's the thing
about like M night like the guy has made
a career of the worst movies ever very
interesting and who always makes money
his movie darts always well your avatar
people hail it as the worst movie ever
made
crushed it all this movies make money
but but here's the thing I don't think
that wasn't like he had some great films
and then a nice little plateau
he literally he's gone back I see I did
see his dude was it good yes but it was
good I've been found by his career
because he started with such an amazing
quote his first one was the Sixth Sense
right semantics and it was like breaking
or unbreakable and then they look at a
sign signs with like oh that was kind of
bad that was kind of bad it's like oh
[ __ ] where are we now but I don't think
I don't think he's like an Ed Wood kind
of figure like I think he's had he has a
large number of bad films under his belt
but he's capable of greatness
we've seen it and I think it's like yes
its bookend by like honestly split was
fun you know he's still [ __ ] at writing
dialogue it's very there are some
cringing moments and split where I just
went oh people don't talk like that
we're heaping a references and stuff yes
you know exactly what yeah it's like
that that Kid movie he made kid movie
the the visit that little kid keeps
wrapping the whole movie and it's so
unbearable I forgot about that I feel
bad for the actor I was like there's no
way you could make this good yeah this
is destined to be bad but that's what I
I have doubt like when I go back and
watch The Sixth Sense it's a masterpiece
and I wonder did he think I think what
happened is that you had a hit and then
they're like can you make more and
there's a lot of money so you maybe you
rush out more movies like I don't also
trapped by his own gimmick of the
twisted twigs yeah I said yeah you're
ready a sixth sense is perfect yeah and
then unbreakable has a nice one and then
it's and then signs what water and
others cetera yeah what that was one of
the worst twists in any movie ever like
my brothers like a meteor like a amateur
meteorologist and he was completely
triggered by that movie
like money the atmosphere is rockin 50
percent water why would you invade a
lava planet I do I made a water glass
nightly filled with lava people right
essentially to that lava
yes it could spit at the aliens and send
the women right we were venomous today a
watery exploit water is absolute toxic
poison they have everything we need
yeah that was a lot of holes in that in
that that gimmick but I mean that I to
to me without the gimmick you know and I
feel like he was maybe he was pressured
I will never know but maybe he was
pressured by studio heads and producers
saying like look we need those twists
mighty that's what that's your that's
your stick yeah you know yeah Hitchcock
did suspense Spielberg did yeah you know
the Spielberg your gimmick is the twist
ending and he maybe you know he kind of
wrote himself in a hole there as a trap
yeah there's a thing about split he
actually I got to see it with Adam from
your movie sucks he was in town and hey
shorty ain't yeah shouts to my boy that
out and he's okay I got this ticket for
this MIT move you want to come it might
be hilarious and we were both walking
out there like well that was good right
there's a little talk from M night at
the end where he was like this was based
on something that I had written into a
much older script and he just like went
through his old files and found like I
guess when you already had been yeah
yeah destroyed by the the notion that he
was the next Spielberg right right
is they too had that there was like a
cover magazine cover it was like the
next Spielberg yeah I think if it's got
a question mark in the headline and it's
not know next Albert and then you put
the pages but oh poor guy I mean what a
headline like that that's you up for so
much I would yeah I would do the same
thing he did I'll be like oh now I got a
suck Yeah right like comenta kit the
next cutie pie and the answer to no
definitely not although I got the hair
for it he's a real heron he got yeah
what did he reach it like what it was he
went to yeah I think isn't Hawaii
he went kauai he did kauai yeah a good
look for you know yeah shout shout Sam
what do you what you guys have any view
to conspiracy theories uh yeah I know we
were talking just a touch about this
outside before um
I mean judge
not really Road dish I don't know what
are yours I've let's look kinetic I've
talked about it so many times on the shy
have so many gas various key theories
well you were you were saying that was
really like this invisible yeah that
yeah that's pretty much it but I feel
like every youtuber I talked to because
you've been through all the ups and
downs of like you know not understanding
why you're getting more or less views
that there is always some you always
trying to figure it out so I'm always
curious if if yeah I got why people have
conspiracy theories I think that all
those companies pulling their ads was
like a front for them just doing poorly
money saying oh you think they weren't
performing yeah I think they're all
going to come back I even made a joke
about that whenever they come back if it
was bad bad fiscal quarter like I don't
think the ads are performing poorly but
I think that like not enough people are
buying Pepsi these days wholly anti
sugar thing and like look right things
have pulled out there was like Pepsi
coke McDonald's well it wasn't limited
at most telecom telecom you know well
that's interesting that area but I mean
if you want to find anti FCC stuff on
the internet you're going to find a
YouTube video or somebody's like
explaining why net neutrality is good
right it's just like I think that a lot
of these companies were like we can save
a lot of money by just blaming this on
Isis saying like I caught a Pepsi I
before an Isis video where they look are
these Isis video right I think what what
yeah I've never seen whatever all one
not all so it's like okay I'm sorry your
ad ran on an Isis video to a hundred
people you don't have to worry about
them buying coke or like you know ruin a
girl yeah I and it also Isis drinks coke
too on the other hand like the suckers
need to drink Pepsi right like that's a
market but the theory I've heard from
people at YouTube yeah was that they
just wanted to de go she ate better race
they used to that's like
leverage it was like wow Jen again still
something kind of ski me it was
definitely Syria right it's not the
surface there's no moral high ground
absolutely not and the server the
explanation doesn't really make sense
really
it doesn't where you guys hit hard by
the boycott I I think I noticed a dip
but it wasn't too bad feel it wasn't too
bad I don't pay I don't think I was able
to like see because like I said I got a
shitty upload schedule so I was like
that could have just been me because I
put one video up that month okay I got
hit guys oh they got me
man you good huh stupid Pepsi what about
you - I didn't I
luckily for whatever reason I did not
feel like I said that family right well
I do I know about you but no yeah it's a
little bit of that and I think I was
somewhat protected by full screen as
well I think it was good yeah yeah so
but I still scared the [ __ ] out of me so
I said maybe like 80% down 80 from what
it was until we all we [ __ ] and we were
posting we were on schedule so yeah oh
yeah that's not that when did you when
did you rally what do you mean I mean
like I mean yeah well from the so you it
would get it get better
yeah well it gradually got a ladder yeah
like month or two past it's probably
it's probably added about like 70% of
where it was last year which is like
obviously I'm really happy that we're
just making moan you know again but for
a minute I was like alright well yeah
time madam [ __ ] let me grab just MC
hiring or yeah that's the right of a sub
what do you guys doing what's your
what's your guys upload schedule these
days is it once a week or a couple times
a week or bury it Mike once a week once
a week okay but we also do this once a
week right of course yeah different
channels but play it and the twitch and
in a perfect world I'd like to upload
like three times a week
of course I noticed you guys were doing
we wear for a while yeah which was
blowing my mind cuz you guys don't make
the daily kind of content I mean lies in
like the cotton it's not what you would
expect to see three or four or five
times a week so that was well they look
unhealthy and that's kind of many was
all we were doing like we yeah you don't
have a life yes I have again totally get
that
so I'm making a conscious conscious
effort these days to kind of balance my
work and personal life because it's just
not help are you like you have that you
have that feeling like oh I'm not
[ __ ] working buddy thing to talk
about that [ __ ] crime though just
which one just ride it off and drop your
arm in the world the rise of the colony
are you guys following the rise of the
poll
yeah what's gonna I try honestly I do
and I don't I try to ignore it until it
hopped up on [ __ ] motors wetter than
I can't
but like otherwise I am blissfully
really different
I tried because because if I do see it
then I'll obsess ya over the numbers and
then a variable again report yeah I know
I agree to take Paul had in the past
three or more today yesterday yeah yeah
whatever you know I know it is 80
million I'm a nanny kid you're a sweet
kid a light sixty oh my oh you're here
you you're sweet try again I don't know
the analytics guys I do know one yes 380
closer really over four right
yeah 484 it 480 hours all Daily News I
am up so [ __ ] glad I don't have kids
so I can say about that yeah that's why
I said I really imagined like you your
kids like I cannot eat a drink Paul's
house and they do and I do what errand
your attorney on business on this wall
that's my thing what happened to parents
like forget about talking what happened
to kids these days when I'm go to
parents business none of us have kids I
think we're under estimating how
annoying kids are my god I would be dead
you [ __ ] go to shake Paul go and n/a
exactly no way yeah go go go dig up
their wall go destroy their house most
this guy I [ __ ] school you shut up oh
great dad
can't wait the solution set up a webcam
outside his house actually awesome kids
up a window that industry yeah before he
does know because you know he will come
here for yeah come on please someone I
love that idea
I don't let's copy write that right now
and sue in the fee I'll put a patent on
do it on live streaming outside Lamar is
already going to have a whole channel
Tim 1212 well we record the hotel what
do you think his daily grind is you need
wakes up and he's like I just had an
idea for a music video
no I think yeah there's there's shadowy
elements on that whole thing oh yeah
they have cheerio yes sir isn't he
should present there no not Disney
that's a different name no they actually
have investors and they have any yeah
there's huge investors in a whole
business team on and is owned by some
shadowy investors and Jake Paul I don't
know how much Jake Paul does there
apparently he's the CEO and so what they
do is it's like a incubation chamber for
[ __ ] boys right of course and so they
bring them into the smell so they buy
them they own these people essentially
like I like here's a camera here's our
your vlog do it daily we own you do it
daily you know they're bang they're like
you're a hot little twink oh they
banging the [ __ ] out of you was that guy
in the other really back to real and
then jacob that you know what our demo
our site is actually what it's about
right that's kind of cold that's how
you'll know when YouTube has made it to
the love of Hollywood yeah the Jay Paul
was sucking smells oh god you're like
all right we made it guys
reality the o-town guy the guy who like
founded in sync and all these boyband oh
yeah a big fat guy he's a real he's got
a lot of rumors about him as well he was
way they suck and he killed himself
why yeah no I think he did in jail low
in jail lose something right really yeah
the story with this guy he was honestly
okay so he was this very sleazy I don't
know what his role was in the founding
of all these boy bands but he helped
whether it was a predict production or
something behind the scenes hmm but he
kind of like helped build in sync and
O'Town like making the band a big
reality show from God the late 90s early
O's you know he was a key figure and all
of that but their ID Lance Bass you know
former NSYNC member once had a horror
story where I think he went up to I'm
gonna butcher this but he went up to Lou
and he and so lose like you want to be a
big star right so nice it's like I guess
and so I think he undid LuAnn undid his
fly said you know what to do and just
[ __ ] like that stories like that are not
uncommon with this character so but then
he was also running this big Ponzi
scheme or some pyramid scheme like The
Bachelor course talked about it and
there I know way too much about boy
bands man I love it but I see a side of
it this is like oh yeah there's this
whole weird aren't [ __ ] the bachelor
boys in their heyday when they're
selling out arenas and [ __ ] they weren't
really getting paid well coordinate not
well I mean they were getting paid but
it didn't add up it didn't add up it
wasn't enough
obviously Lou was you know kind of kind
of holding on to something and then
finally it was revealed that you know
he's running this big scheme so they
sent
to prison and I think he died in prison
and he was banging them so he was
scamming them I'm not going to say
banging but he was trying metaphor again
literally yeah you kind of banging them
that's what Hawley was all about I think
it's a matter of time until that happens
in like team ten or something no I right
you're right not talking about the no I
think you're right yeah yeah the pyramid
scam that's pretty much just what we're
seeing that's why I'm so fascinated by
Jake and Logan Paul and Team Tennis
because I on YouTube has never seen
anything like this before the right like
Jake and logo father like rapper status
at this point yes they roll around with
posses they have investors as big you
know the investors thing is blowing they
do it right okay they have like you've
seen the music videos like the
originally the contents garbage but
they're shot and edited very well built
on the backs of a lot of people with
like drones for cheap mm-hmm yeah just
like hey keep watching the flyer drone
over my house and just matter what it's
going to be beautiful shots I will give
them but that they have a team they
don't they don't you guys don't edit
anything don't they probably didn't know
if they don't know yeah I don't know if
that was I know I was very dry but I'm
actually surprised though they don't
know I shouldn't be surprised
Jake ball on recently on his second
general he uploaded a reaction through
our reaction to his video okay and when
others like I want to stress but anyway
you reacted to videos about his everyday
bro yeah and the way that video is made
really shows you can tell his skill set
they're basically just sitting at a
table the sound is awful it shows I'm
gonna well you're just watching the
video on your laptop and there's no cuts
it's not even edited now I want to watch
oh that's disgusting forgot to edit out
spark camera guy named Lou comes in and
you know what he everything all right
fellas I want you guys to watch this
because we thought about in here yeah
yeah I thought about making an HD video
about it but it was just so obscenely
god it's like it'll all be gonna make me
down man it's good I finally get you
well is this for me is like a good
insight to what he's actually capable
joy yeah content wise first off is
really well lit I like their their idea
board on the back I mean the name of
this test tube is trying to write a
script
you reacted beautify bamaca this makes
no sense ready like a Mario level he
does on my dad you may get it okay here
it is yeah de now that's some stupid
hair you know always think about Jake
yeah first off because it's recording
the sound off at any louder yes it
sounds great things on your budget is
showing I don't understand why would
they do that because he clearly synced
the video up to what they're watching
but they took the audio in favor of a
shitty right so the room sounds like the
microphone is like ten feet away so good
elected at every reverb be really don't
underestimate the quality of a practical
effect it's practical effects George
Lucas review I want to predict what he's
gonna say I want to predict what I want
him to say something like what the [ __ ]
is even wearing man he looks like such a
tool man he looks so [ __ ] gay alright
cool so I can't really disappointed cuz
this is what he says this what he says
oh so so a jinx level of very actual
reasons cool cool god I came in here the
V over like all this debt is so bad
you forgot that this is being recorded
you just watch the videos so the bit the
whole video is unedited not even a
single [ __ ] cut I can't do that I
mean you can well you know Jake
Pollard's are the strongest in the world
but oh my man so why don't you say did
you have them all queued up and he's
just like control tabbing or oh I'll be
watching you say was Jake father new oh
yeah let's take like ya know how to edit
on all the quality goes in daily Paul
one that's higher that's fair not read
that maybe he was just staring at your
Oliver thinking yeah what overthinking
issue yeah I got a million wife and
comic comment one I made sure but I
think I shot this man before it will
happen frequent anything correctional
consulate yeah I heard that you just say
I passed this man in three months he did
say that today but I want to have a beer
with him he feels like really cool
humble guys drink no I think he's 100
kids 20 he's definitely getting banged
by the way if he's not old number drink
you so much banging him right area are
you talking about an old man
oh yeah old man's back you know what I
love about Jake's SEC acts like he's a
sex icon but here's what I like I mean
look at him this might be below the belt
but the color how he's pushing the air
over his forehead like Sudha knows he's
going bald and it don't worry okay
you'll get hair plugs in three years you
can we completely Gauls you know a
little girl you'll be fine I'm bill cos
frosty know a decent as a Ludlow how
[ __ ] dare you can't agree more and
meanwhile good looking for just little
while awfully what up hair what up pay
up it's probably a low blow but I take
some how I revel in the fact that I know
he's gonna he's already going bald hey
Jake it happens to the best of us okay
buddy don't even worry about it alright
it's inevitable night why you may want
to brush that for
yeah I'm trying to I'm trying right come
on first of all I think a receding
hairline is dignified and beautiful in
your case thank I love you what a lovely
compliment shaken you know you don't
even have a receding hairline
you got hair for days I just got too
much hair care secret Oh hair okay
that's it that hair the secret did you
get this thing is a curse I don't know
you could shave like three pineapples in
the mud very good literally so a [ __ ]
sweater from this I'm like a summer her
sheep issue I need to give it I need to
get sheared or else has died that's what
happens if she they gradually do they
let her see spec by the way oh that's
evolution like taking a wrong or Scott
wrong [ __ ] where's God sheep he
abandoned them here's the surface yeah
but back to Jake Paul what a what a
charm anyway we had a charmer I feel
like I spent way too much time talking
about Jake ball but it's like so fun
well it doesn't hard not to talk about
it it's like I mean it's a hot dogger
thing like so it's not like yeah six
months from now we'll be talking about
someone else you know the new the next
guy was well button thing I always say
about Jake Paul's like thank God for him
because YouTube for me as a professional
[ __ ] talker and complainer I was running
out the pranksters were dead you know I
was running out of father people yeah
exactly I'm like oh kind of damn boy
you've got look at Renaissance 18 and is
good absolutely Christmas every day with
him for every day bro forgive me oh
thank you thank you but there's been
some interesting developments I want
tell you guys well here we go
so in his you guys saw the news report
where he was playing at you okay so now
essentially and his vlogs he's accused
his neighbors vs. neighbors he made a
video apologizing to them but he
recorded it without telling them and
then he posted to Zoo cha as you know in
California that's illegal right they
have a you can't you need their consent
it rank up with you they're in a video
he didn't tell them he didn't get their
consent and put in as well the guy's
such an idiot right so now they're
falling a eavesdropping complaint
against them yeah and then now the same
news guys is covering this story then it
gets better
better than in the next vlog he says he
accused his neighbor's of trying to kill
him on
ironically he accused his neighbors of
going up to their team ten man and
unbolting the tires that resulted in a
crash he says my neighbor's literally
tried to kill me even though there is
that the titles that the UM the title of
the video my name is literally try to
kill I wish it were her entity he got
some the actual title was something like
my wife is living me in parentheses said
I learn now by the way many kids that's
the real cutter yeah yeah the new pain
the new thing on YouTube is like telling
you what kind of emotions yeah right
right or not clickbait as a hot one not
quickly just you know that's run like
seven ninety percent of my videos that
are quickly list time I'm serious this
time I thought oh my GAD guys nicely
played alright there's another I don't
know that I can tell there's another
thing that's even better than that but
I'm think I can talk about it yeah we
should we should wait and see how things
are you best yeah well done do that you
yeah yeah I'll see you guys off the
water yeah yeah well I'll tell you
happen yeah we can cut this short
[ __ ] it good loser TGI Fridays right on
me and that's anyway so that's up with
me a lot of money I was really fun
little rabbit mole oh yeah I bet should
so interesting you know there's
definitely like a click is sort of the
reason people watch TMZ and stuff like
that yeah oh absolutely we love to hang
outside our world yeah oh uh they set
their pool on fire yeah yeah my
neighbors never done that right right
the flames were reached higher than the
house which is [ __ ] kidding me
yeah more [ __ ] neighborhood man
seriously I do feel how are you gonna
end the thing that when he's like my
neighbor's tried to kill me to all the
five million dumb ass fans who are even
dumber than he is right been jobbed um
Jake Paulus divided by half that's how
dumb his fans whoa
just half come on man a fraction that's
barely functioning that's like that's
like struggling to breathe well what got
me and we were talking about a little
bit about this beforehand was just the
fact that a he has his address you know
publicly available yeah
so it's a Google and look up and be that
12 11 10 year-old girls are outside it
at all times
yeah at all times that's creepy as [ __ ]
apparently we got an email tell nobody
from the neighbor wait we got an email
from his neighbor or someone knows a
neighbor and there was a quote from the
neighbor you know right but no we got an
email from someone saying I know the
neighbor we live across the street from
him and they're like I'm there right now
it's 12:30 p.m. and there's like 30
girls outside his house right now wait I
didn't read that I want that neighbor on
yeah I did not just oh my god
so yeah their neighbors are losing it
and the secretaries I'll imagine now
that that's your reality yeah and now
he's saying they tried to kill me and so
imagine what his insane fans are going
to do when they think that that person
is trying to murder our Idol neighbors
do they're going to vandalize their
house we can break the windows they made
they're probably gonna kill them plan
how does he know that the neighbors did
it he doesn't the addresses public sign
ages right anyone could have done any
third address public that's got to be
the stupidest thing I can do that's
pretty but sweet [ __ ] low yeah well
the funny thing is now I've seen
pictures of that front of the house
since all this shit's gone down and it's
just so vandalized yeah I know it's like
graffiti on the garage for signing the
wall and the themes on house yeah I
think it's so the investors own the
house right so that's why they're not
being evicted and that's why they're
like I'm good I'm just gonna flip and
ship it or whatever he says my
neighbor's hate me but I'm just going to
finish and it we got a room in the back
that we really need to host down but
don't that habit we're out of here yeah
I don't mean anything by that
yeah Oh Jake knows what you mean yeah
but you know the whole thing is just
it's fascinating it's all new
yeah all wild it's all it's so much to
[ __ ] keep up with because it's a new
story every day every day hate that
that's a mean I think that that is every
day bro with that gonna take Channel I
get a song stuck in my head and pretend
he never write he will do that's why he
wins you know and I I just like it very
much
- he saw
I use off the hatred he drives which is
good I prefer that than getting
defensive
no it's healthy I'm just very healthy to
thrive I wish I could talk about that
other thing
I'm not going to I'll take a dump all
right you tzg so what I've got a
question for you guys to [ __ ] pivot
hard off the subject close the crease on
me let's take off [ __ ] a hard letter
yeah and hopefully not flip I mean for
me
YouTube such a emotional rollercoaster
like do you have these like emotional
ups and downs I mean it seems like you
you're just chilling you don't [ __ ]
care about anything yeah man it's all
big money to me baby well but I'd like
you've been in the game you up looks
like very frequently for me it's like
this constant emotional rollercoaster
trying to be like saying I get like
super depressed
I feel like bipolar because you have
like these super highs when you have a
good video that people like and do well
and you have super lows you make a video
that people don't like or you're not
posting enough videos and it's like how
do you navigate that space and say
saying I struggle oh yeah I struggle
with that a lot because it's you go
through inspirational cycles you know so
it's like there are some days where I'm
really [ __ ] pumped like I got the
best idea ever and I paced the house
right talking to my girl trying to flesh
out the joke and rights and everything
and how it's going to be edited and all
that stuff and I know I'm making myself
laugh and crack up like oh this is good
I write down then you have the days
where you got nothing you're running on
empty you know and those days really
suck and I'm like I think there's not
much I can do I scream at my poor dogs
like I said I'm so happy that my fiance
Aaron has an office job so that I can
have the house to myself and just go
bonkers with my just soul self conflict
it's a lot of self-doubt too I've been
working on this this joke that I just
don't want to film because I don't know
if it's funny enough and you have this
self-doubt like it's so weird funny is
it funnier on paper rather than if I
flush it out and film it and stuff and
it's just all this like I keep saying
self-doubt because that's really what it
is like I don't know funny I don't know
if they're gonna think it's funny so I
don't do it then nothing gets made and
then and then you know people look to
stuff like we're
book is yah and I'm like I don't want to
make you doing [ __ ] me I want to make
something that I was something different
or sometimes I do want to make you hype
it's like if it's an inspired episode
where I'm actually putting a lot of
energy into um like you said highs and
lows ups and downs there's I don't know
I haven't found a way to like cope with
I'll be honest I don't there's no ego to
solution where it's like oh I know what
to do I don't know what to do I have
good days where I'm inspired I have bad
days where there's just nothing in the
tank and it sucks and hopefully you have
a backlog like well maybe I can upload a
best-of something on those days but it's
there's no easy solution of you know
like thinking back when I worked in an
office shop for five years I didn't have
these [ __ ] manic you know Twitter is
interesting and then you don't you come
home and you're done we're done on your
day I turn off you know like everyone's
like okay first of all yes I'm doing my
dream job
Google explaining right yeah unique I
think it's important to be like this
it's not that I mean emotionally it's
really dad that's the problem it's more
than complaining and so you can kind of
lose your mind so yes you can in
actually what we can fall into yourself
yeah I mean this stuff pretty easily
because there's nobody to tell you what
to do it's like I could fall into those
eyes of your daughter here - daily a
point of talking about yeah yeah you're
not real you can't get realized oh man
they're powerful here you know tweet the
Ted Cruz let's go that's what you know
where's my dance for me dance for me oh
no it is a thing though like um you know
you could do you could start having your
own inside jokes or you're like oh
people want these inside jokes amano-san
yeah but then like you there's other
people who are like why does he keep
saying the same thing right it may Leah
Nate's the new viewer and you don't want
to do that but you want to keep the
old-timers happy so you got include that
right is this give and take this balance
like comment and yeah all the comments I
mean I get called a fat sweaty piece of
[ __ ] but I know that they mean it with
love they I might stoke those flames
somehow those moments don't bother me as
much
yeah that's more like people something
like we don't like them anymore or like
like this channel is gone to [ __ ] yeah
that's the worse well yeah yeah like who
are they didn't bother me but it does
well those are in a sea of 15,000
comments per video or what have you
those are the ones that it's sucking
they stand out you don't have you know
you don't ya know exactly because
they're like for one of those there are
20 like a wheel in the illa I really got
my life yeah you help me find everyone
huff time I remember though if you
remember though like man I remember one
you can either were funny it is it
that's true it's gotta be something like
it's probably always been that way for
entertainers you just never have a open
forum right level low the content where
you can see what people think on in an
anonymous right way you know like I
always try to imagine like comment
section on there like Netflix oh yeah
now is the base I show that color that's
there was live comments in comments
under like Jimi found my backhoe and go
to work anymore I thought what it's
waited years ago god I saw the question
sweet today that's totally make fun
Italy ribbon on Fallon it was like the
in the context of the tweet oj was his
guest and so he's like man I just
actually oj was his guest right no no
like Genoveva talked about like you know
if he were on the show and now that he's
you know so the tweet was like he's
talking about saying like yeah Jimmy I
just really want to talk about blah blah
and then found like that's great man but
now we're gonna play a game called get
that shoes and it was perfect it was so
like that's in a box it was so like and
it sucks because I had heard him like
well I loved Fallon growing up on like
90s and early O's SNL I loved when he
broke character in left I really I know
a lot of people hate when he does all
like hey what room and it's worked for
him and when he and horatio sanz were
buddy-buddy on SNL like they would just
destroy every sketch there and the
sketch was instantly better so I there's
a weird kid wasn't that good to begin
with it really really that's not a nice
habit of dragging on sketches for way
too long they always have and that
especially then but it just kind of like
he gets memes on and he kind of deserves
it let's be real everything's
everything's again
name celebrity celebrity beer pong you
know but he shouldn't he million bodies
this like fake niceness
not the other one he's way too [ __ ]
happy-go-lucky right yeah he gets off
every movie is the best drink puppy you
know you know he does probably rapes a
public rapes a [ __ ] dick right in there
you heard it here guys at on the h3h3
podcast by 210 them how their mom they
supply the puppies they've got they've
got a puppy mill they got that big house
you know do you feel that though Eric
are you like more chill oh yeah what
we're talking about
my turn slow down so yeah absolutely cuz
like you know I'm not I made a joke
earlier where I said my upload schedule
sucks because I'm just sitting around
drinking playing video games but I'm
like I've got Google Docs open in front
of me and I'm writing this thing I'm
like is this funny yeah yeah I honestly
can't tell and I'll like read it out
loud to myself nope that wasn't funny
but I don't know how to fix it and I'll
just deleting we're not delete it but
I'll just go on to something else well I
want a man that that's something that
hits me is like you're working super
hard but you have nothing to show for it
yeah yeah I complained that exact point
to Aaron just about every night I've
made those literal words I got nothing
to show for it you know and and she'll
always provide a very strong
counter-argument and I go you're right
honey you everybody
god bless you got you know no she's um
but um wait it's no true and it's so
frustrating because then you know then
you don't upload that week or a couple a
lot a couple of days and people think
you're lazy yeah the [ __ ] is my content
where's my where's my free content I
paid good money for this yeah I'm so
envious of people who just like turn on
the cameras like alright well if I can
hey how you doing I'm gonna [ __ ] around
and there you go not even going to look
at it it's up now and people love it
but I think that's the obstacle that I'm
trying to get over where it's like I
found that when I have that self doubt
and I'm like this isn't funny
[ __ ] this that 90% of time people love
it yeah for example our new video about
Jake Paul yeah we didn't want to post it
me mostly well I mean I felt understood
what you're saying but I'm like I'm
always the ones like what's not uploaded
like let's just that's interesting
related are you laying out like the
reaction when you say that or is it more
like you you
watch it and you're like oh I don't know
close quote I'm like yeah it's both I
don't think I I can't even trust my
judgment anymore
I always think everything is not good
and then I'm like what people are not
going to like it and that's interesting
so my attitude to counter hers is just
like we did our best
this is our video for the week yeah if
you don't like it they understand and
they want something so I'm not going to
throw away like I used to do is really
right like we upload the video and then
they love it yeah and then if I watch it
in like two months I'm fine with it and
I laugh at it and I think it's all
that's interested when you're looking at
the one you guys were on now yeah she's
got a bet is that one yeah it's gotta
yeah age like fine
Rosa Jenna does salt to like walk away
from something I've done that a couple
times yeah yeah I just did a one on
music videos yeah and I I'd had that
written for like months hot dad the guy
who does my theme song highlights out
that oh yeah he's made some music for us
oh really
yeah I don't know that we have maybe
he's a shadow master behind the scene
sad I was everywhere now I wouldn't be
surprised music and video games are shy
he's smart Adam now like he had made
that cover a long time ago when I told
him about the idea and like like I told
him about the idea in a week later he's
like all right I did it
Wow got this song ready when are you
putting yours up and whoa hey man I'll
even now I'm making it a circle and I
edited that [ __ ] thing for I wanted
that thing to go up last week on Monday
and it took me until like two days ago
to actually finish it just editing like
staring at it like this is that's
alright I'm gonna kiss this is not good
I cut like five minutes out of that well
ten minutes long pile so I I don't know
what's worked for me that I suggest and
obviously it's hard to take advice on
this level but a big change for me was
when I just I'm like I'm not going to
get caught up on this because the nature
of YouTube you know we're not making a
show on television where you mean we
spend a year on ten episodes and very
few just got a [ __ ] dude I let it
just let it go let it live its own life
and move on the nature of YouTube is
very stream of conscious
yeah it is like those raisins logs are
so prevalent on there because it's just
hey guys what I'm doing today right it
doesn't matter we cleared that Chad's
popular - it's a stream that's a perfect
analogy stream consciousness for the
moment I think I think yeah for me
getting over that hang-up was was like
really was really big for us and like I
said I think you'll be surprised how
many times you put out a video you're
not happy with because just in that and
the spirit of I'm just going to let this
go and it does great and everyone loves
it and nobody even sees what you were
worried about yeah there's a little
something about it that like as a
magical ingredient in it because you
hate it so much
yeah what that is absolutely are you
just like well this sucks is going to do
terrible friend but it's always got your
essence in it like as long as what
you're putting out is you do you know I
mean it's because that's why people
ultimately subscribe to channel it's not
really for the content but for the
personality in the content you know I
mean I mean like Constance got to be
good too but it's also like they like
your take on saying yeah no they like
you and they want you to be part of
their lives yeah it's like yeah here's
my here's the bestest sorry guys is the
best I could do this week yeah and I
think that if you really are like
struggling with something that you're
working on you're going to put way more
work into that have a much more polished
end product and something that you loved
that is sorry this is great the way I
did it at this time that happens that's
what people watch it you then you watch
that a week later and you're like oh
that sucked should I should have done
that better than so we we read these
sponsors
oh yeah after that we'll take a short
break very short break and then we have
a new segment we're working on when I'm
very happy to include you guys in we
have a new segment offbeat news some
crazy wild news that our producer cam
the birthday boy is going to come read
to us love it and I'd love for you guys
to be part of that but if you guys they
want to take a break now you don't
consider for you don't know this but
your what means like I'm you know
writing four out of ten a to the ride
we're in for the long haul baby alright
well let's begin here with these guys I
got to thank our sponsors they make the
show possible if it wasn't for them we
wouldn't have creamer in the office
today putting our coffee which is huge
we're really we're getting the luxuries
of life here thanks to these guys in
this whole damn show so first off me
undies have you
you guys know about me on DS no key tell
us about me on DS me on DS is native
every pair of me on DS is sustainably
sourced and made from micro modal micro
modal checked out give that a few couple
fielded you know if you put against your
family pillow soft it is Oh like my
favorite thing about that's soft to sell
racism yeah unbelievable fabric what the
hell does it for you goes up didn't
realize yeah they were very kind reach
baby I'm talking about
and they actually yeah this once what I
do love about them
I got a dear friend I do like the
colorful designers Hall thank you take
that home thank you nan Warren unwinding
oh great
this really will hug me undercarriage
that is some that will take care of you
yeah on those hot summer la days got to
be German engineering and cousins all
right whatever they're just big fat they
make the best cars and so you know
that's the best micro mobile so this is
some great colorful it's probably the
most comfortable underwear you can get
they don't also have underwear they've
shirts and sweaters made of this
wonderful fabric if you guys go to me
undies calm /h 3 you can get 20% off
your first pair plus free shipping and
if you don't love them they're free they
used to have this promotion where you
would ship back your used undo I love
that that's ingenious and sometime
College somehow I miss that first time
we did them with like alright well
they're going to bed your dirty onto the
deal like it but now now they swish it
to their free so if you don't like him
you get the key point I think that's a
better choice for everyone it's been
with ya all personally I wonder the heck
out of this product they've been a huge
sponsor a great sport bus so if you guys
are in the market for some very
comfortable colorful fun did you believe
it's a Jubilee nowhere jelly there's a
word that you know way more play is a
party downtown
nice so go to me Andy's calm /h 3 get
your free or not free pair sorry slows
down $25 free shipping though
all right thank you to me undies thank
you you guys thank you for the freemium
you should I send you this when it's
dirty yes and then yeah that's a mailman
hates that just doing you don't even
package all the label on it there we go
yeah so cool then about star next up
we've got audible who doesn't love
audible who among us does not live all
can't think of a single person no I am
drying so audible if you guys don't know
is the biggest supplier of audiobooks
they've got everything you could dream
of and I mean first of all beyond having
a great product they are such a great
supporter of online content they've
seriously one of the original champions
of supporting content creators or that I
love them but like if you're exercising
you're gaming you're in team if you're
camping out clean ten mmm you know you
gotta listen to something you gotta
listen to something put this on its
going to make it ten times better
I mean exercise is excruciating I need
something to take my mind off that [ __ ]
so I put on audible I've been jamming
The Dark Tower the original Dark Tower
on audible recently since the movies
coming out this Stephen King you guys
read that one
I've yes I've read all idea how do you
look tired yeah years ago are you
tonight up for the movie I I got high
hopes like anything okay - there's a
long time coming they've been working on
this movie 4 p.m. and the book he's not
it's not a black the or I guess they
don't talk about the day I don't think
they serve a race ever but in all the
illustrations he is he is a white
gunslinger but I mean like I know I just
either I love him yeah oh yeah he's such
a wire
he's like one my favorite KK go wrong
with him he's so great he's great and
everything yeah I dare someone out there
I dare me
come on - anybody with memory well ok so
I first saw him and the wire and he is
like is incredible like Brooklyn accent
and he's and then when I saw an
interview with him he has this thick
English accent it's always worth a look
upon yeah yeah the UM blue English
actors they always pull in over me man
like him - it's not the other way around
like you never
yeah because if it's mas might have been
in a series in kate winslet i think
played like a british ally and something
but like and that's it that you
attention to the rule to yeah meanwhile
i feel like they're making fun of us
when these english out i'll we go to
dollars and they yeah and i don't even
know they don't even take a look on just
say yeah just like yeah it's easy you
just thank them don't look at america so
anyway the dark tower is one of stephen
king's most prolific is a trilogy right
or no amor no it's one of seven oh my
god yeah the dark night series does this
all we infer like a new harry potter if
the movie does well well it's exciting
we'll see so the doctor anyway the dark
power is a great read and it's a great
listen if you go to audible.com slash h3
podcast get a free audiobook with a 30
day free trial
check out the dark tower while you're
exercising camping out team 10 you won't
regret it so if you're in the market for
some undies go to me undies comm /h if
you're in the market for an audiobook
and some great free entertainment you
have nothing to lose enough to send
dirty on these back or anything in this
case I mean either in Mandy's do you get
them for free there go to audible.com
slash a street podcast and get a free
audiobook big dark tower thank you to
our sponsors thank you to you guys for
doing that and sporting the show we're
going to take a quick quick bathroom
break and we'll be back with the newest
this is a great segment this isn't just
the news I'm not talking about politics
these are offbeat stories that you will
not want to miss and if you leave
something terrible is guaranteed to
happen to you yeah bizarre news baby
bizarre love it ok we'll be back in one
short minute guys don't roll off this
shirt alright guys we are back with h3
podcast we've got drinks on deck and
before we go to the new segment
something really spicy just happened so
we're probably make a video about this
but Austin posted alone texted me a
couple days ago he's like Jake Paula
just showed up at my house and I was
like how the [ __ ] did that happen and so
Austin ordered Jake Palmer ironically
for a video we're going to make and they
took it very seriously they missed the
irony which is fine because the tweet
was pretty ambiguous but the thing that
was insane is that Jake Paul extracted
his address
from the merge company which has got to
be so illegal he shows up at his house
to hand-deliver the merge but here's the
worst [ __ ] part he showed the front
of his [ __ ] house in his vlog he
filmed it and showed the front of his
house and I know he just moved too which
makes it even worse
Eric you described what would be your
choice words for this uh well you know I
was thinking that maybe that wasn't
quite legal yeah I'm starting to think
that maybe it's they're gonna have to
start calling at t9 this is what yeah
like everything it was done like this
man this kid has no filter is no
boundary yeah that's it but he started
you know he's just really cool cabbage
all right and that's why these 10 year
old girls love him cuz he's just a
savage boy yeah I can't believe how [ __ ]
did this keep just broadcasted that's
disgusting
no I was alone he's got that VEVO money
right he's on that short oh [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with VEVO they're everywhere
even her not me people have come to you
but I want to show you I haven't watched
this it just got posted up yeah it's
heard about so I want to watch it for
the first time yeah I feel so bad for
Austin yeah I mean you know what you
just don't do that look he blurred the
little on the curb like the address but
you see the whole town all the cool it's
so easy yeah they found that Shia LeBouf
slag out in the middle of a field and
for him exactly exactly through through
the the jet contrails so when I found
out about this from Austin we were both
like this is so illegal and sketchy but
now that I'm seeing what he actually
showed I'm actually outraged even more
he's gonna have to take that down he's
gonna have like all now this video is
going to be taken sorry been downloaded
eighty thousand times I'm sure let me
download it the damn Harry thank you let
me keep it out just like hey guys
welcome to t9 on bill can digging over
for Jake pants Alvin I am 50 year old
man Jake all you better start sucking
dicks now cuz that's all I can give you
at this point dude this kid is such a
train wreck man this is so [ __ ] up
it's you know it's a good lesson
and what not to do yeah all those air
wiring you there's out there we don't do
that if you're like an up-and-coming
youtuber maybe don't show the Front's of
houses a stranger especially if they're
vivo and maybe don't let it get to your
head so much that you blast somebody's
address all right let's see what
actually he put in his vlog well first
of all let me say I can't hear it to any
Turnitin food I want to hear his creamy
voice um their prophetic description for
voice before it's creamy I'm I'm sorry
it's cream god damn that maybe you
shouldn't showed that shot dumb if he's
gonna want to talk to you right now like
well we're not are we are showing it I
mean he already showed it to millions of
people yeah but it'd probably take it on
this video will stay up or you should do
it pose well done don't show it on
Python that's easier okay so how do I do
it so maybe don't show it I'm just going
to listen to it yeah just don't show it
so don't show the TV I'll turn it off
but I do want the sound okay so here the
first shot starts with he's just the
camera is just on his house and there's
a little rectangle with that the actual
address which is blurred but everything
else including though this is his house
he's got like Rolls Royces and whatnot
to get some estimates they didn't wear
out the leg alignment they did not wear
out the licenses they're not legible oh
not that it [ __ ] matters oh here you
go Wow keep whatever like fifth grade
music is I was like oh it soft again
plus one hate to throw whatever it's all
good though we're gonna dab on the
haters but then my boy post on Twitter
this tweet he orders our merchandise a
lot of it a lot of it which we have it
right here
core so I'm super confused I don't know
why he ordered on think about it
idiot he's one of my best friend he does
it well irony is a very complicated word
for a boy like you know he did theirs it
doesn't exist he's like what irony can I
dab on it is done confused yeah
it doesn't take much of computer serial
so let's go I booked maybe lectures when
they go to his house and broadcast it to
the world that'll get him quick plan
great merchandise when he was talking
smack about us right now we're about to
hand-deliver it to his house he lives
like 45 minutes away we're gonna give
him is March hopefully he's home and
we're gonna confront him and ask him
like yo why would you talk smack and
then order our merch and then hopefully
we can that guy legal that's not legal
somebody ordering your merch from a
third-party company doesn't it tied you
to steal their address and then display
it to millions of people in your videos
you don't get it man he just wants to
talk with him and then flog it anyway no
it's like it I just wish he had an older
brother maybe stay away from doing it
don't shine media you know what Logan
Paul I saw I was like maybe he's laying
low and he's going to talk to his
brother his older brother his most
recent video I checked this morning is
reacting to the Jake Paul drama he's
mirroring it really they're not even
brothers he's just a fellow clone of
turned out to stupid-looking a video
right Ryan these guys want to bang and
then he hits me Jake hit me in the damps
and he says I want to make a song with
you and post hmm I didn't answer
yeah wait Jake had you in the DM yeah oh
yeah I was gonna I wanted to wait to see
what he did with this because I was
gonna because previously we had talks
into dm's and he was a nice guy he had
talked about coming on the podcast and I
thought about having him come on shore
my concern was that he was going to come
and act insane right and have a
liability of course the app dab jokes
yeah I mean that you know how many times
can you dab on the hair this is okay for
anyway
so this is what this is kind of just I
don't know I don't know that I can this
is [ __ ]
yeah
this is post Hong know
okay guys should we hear it like a
quarter-mile away I don't know how this
is about to go down we don't know if
he's home we don't know if he hates us
or just gets used in general let's get
it what makes you think that it's cool
to go to his house so he's showing the
front house showing his car's wrong kind
of nervous going up she's showing the
front floor and I if I made a video at
our house I would never show the front
or the front door never never ever you
guys had AI dogs climbing yeah yeah and
that even that was too risky
yeah okay yeah this might work for the
joke video but we were worried about in
terms of the front door they're both
there they've got a lot of cameras there
it's Austin here we got two minds
they're recording Austin it like I don't
even know that he's being he knows his
be reporter this works the most legal
right Austin saying what's going on we
would can deliver if I thought like you
were somewhere back there granitic
manager the defense song a new daughter
away will I do nothing more so you know
they are their shitty obsessive no no
boundary fans don't look at about the 10
year old girls up my ass and Tempe he
nor the behavior analysis it's okay not
going yeah you know it's really good
everybody knows my dad drove me wait can
I open it so you guys can at least watch
along - on TV is that too risky
maybe it's bad that we listen because
we're like the viewers we go yeah you
get roll and cut to it in the man yeah
yeah we create we get the picture you're
already blogging right we like him so
yeah but yeah we're friends right we go
in
hang on input and write you like ball
skills and show this footage in our
church people in the case that okay
study like to thank you already know
your savage I love your music and things
so we're like yell we are hand-delivered
the March thank you sir lucky for them
post is a nice guy yeah yeah nice guy
goes way nicer
yeah a less nicer person would have yeah
sure that I've got my property huh
stupid kid or just be shotgun blast
movie really dark that'd be a good blood
I had no doubt that Austin would just be
nice because is nice he text me is like
you won't believe what just happened
yeah what not only feels like Jake Paul
just came to my [ __ ] house I see a
little bit of explanation because it's
like you were kind of like hippy about
the song where you're lying but then you
got the March so dude he's [ __ ]
moving on it you are the purchase fire
you know a small video me me on him in
his own video but my yard is way over
his head
he wanted to merge for sketch that we're
gonna make right thank you so much for
having me on the show today could the
timing be matter o'clock with the time
is limited we get to witness this it's a
beautiful thing where were you right
I'll never forget I'll never win I'm
stuck with little boy got himself
incarcerated I'm the thing is like
thankful was writing so highs invincible
but somehow he found a way no she's on
like this uncredible nosedive do you
think well you think so I mean yeah well
this is illegal no illegal to sell
illegal this is straight-up lawsuit you
lost everything like if Austin wants to
press charges are suing I'm sure I
Stanley worden
because he's not all right I'm not
people nice the guy showed up at his
house about to I'm not sure also there's
a precedent to be set because I mean
yeah post Maloney is a very popular
musician he has a team of lawyers yeah
Oh
anything like this and be like well
Janna would you like to bury him yeah
I'll show it flexibility the merged
company the murder guy the way this in
okay Jake Paul cells has merged through
fan joy which is a huge emerge company
right handed in his address is a whole
line of your we gotta believe I'm
scrupulous illegal yeah so while are
going to go down for this it seems like
it's the new Watergate tailgate wait
what okay so Jason on about it Paul gate
yeah okay no oh that's good that's just
gate this needs to be h3 video it will
be I think we just need to know how to
make a whole video and then make the
parody you got old
yeah a couple of is there you guys got
you gawking about having time so I'm
looking line that on with all day I know
you've got it
I need a bus men up for Adrienne can we
just like can we just take take a step
back and just here's a situation where
I'll just drinking some nice ice-cold
Hennessy while witnessing the downfall
of the most notorious yes absolutely
cheers here to the fallen the fall of
the poem was like what sorry I'm going
to click my damn glass swatch up you
know it's funny because they just made
they made a music video called the rise
of apology ah well that was quick yeah
they really am night is this one there's
a I'm sore about water killed them I
gotta see what's out there you got to do
anything with it but we got another song
and as a verse open is there can you
imagine post Malone a pop superstar
doing a verse on Jake Paul like how
delusional you get the look on on
Austin's face right now is the face of
somebody who's like man you [ __ ] up
right [ __ ] you up
what have you done hi carrie has out
wrong by though using dolphin sounds the
censorship yeah stupid news
zombie fella work for a monkey
that one so well that one so you are in
the corner this is the most corner gets
us the other sniper shot yeah but he's
gonna be on my sonic when you saw no
yeah yeah no probably should I got his
number you know where that because I'm
not he just travels just like know where
we live a little too real
yep oh my [ __ ] now I so well what are
they doing right there yeah well max are
they going to zoom in on the exact
location it's like really yeah it's like
a Google Maps thing on now okay I don't
know if it's yeah it's I don't think
that it's accurate well I think it's
gonna zoom in nope nope all right Nick
it's random okay okay not so cool so he
see the comments yeah publicly made the
I think we'll be fine okay yeah they'll
be fine
that went so well you're getting me that
was great can I um any songs
well more can you ask for Christ I'm
shocked and awed by this yeah me too
this is so weird
it is beautifully assistant I know yeah
somebody just filled our food bowl I
just blown away by how reckless and
irresponsible a king of egg it's just
part of the UM weird new segments that
are new so you're talking about so cool
hey we win we won our new this is our
lead story but I did oh great bit oh I
really need to hear back from awesome
that's hilarious
oh what's always what is probably only a
message right lawyers are how many
lawyers yes probably what a message Dre
and tell him to check that yeah all
right let's get let's let's focus we
need to make HD video of this though
this is absolute bananas this is
priority number one for you guys let's
cut it short go go go alright let's
let's move it on let's do the news here
are we are we set up where I gotta grab
that back okay go ahead let's kiss so
anyway dance corner well I have a hard
time nobody I get I get that was quite a
quite a development that we got to
witness live yeah
there yeah like watching the Towers fall
you know exactly that level I mean all
right well I like that lesson yeah I'm
sorry Allah arable and I hate when it
like one victim here sadly which is
possible long yeah well so I'm hobbling
I think posters give it a win in the end
yes to do I think he's got the upper
hand hope he doesn't have to move or
anything he literally just moved there
like a couple weeks ago oh really he
literally was like I'm going to take the
day off to put all the boxes away
because my house looks like a dump and
I'm a poor person gosh definitely dick
move dick move no this guy's got [ __ ]
investors and you're like trying to [ __ ]
through a legal team that's representing
look when you waterboard someone dick
does it dick moves yeah yeah it's your
exact it's just very very common
simulated drowning Yoda clue what are
you doing why'd he do that
I wish you just could've asked I could
tell you I'll talk or explosion next we
are setting up for the new segment that
was a bit of a tangent but I thought it
was an important one that was beautiful
and not well worth the time well worth
it real give it a second here Dan you've
made my day
oh boy in fun it is to ride pretty crazy
that happened doing the podcast oh my
god thank you
like everything else he's done has been
pretty pretty much a footnote to that
one yeah yeah yeah it's good it'll get
hella views
it'll get hella press um I just hope to
god it develops into something else and
it's not just another brick in the jake
paul wall you know what i mean like i
hope that this actually like is because
you can compare like trunk to this you
know Trump says all this Atlanta's [ __ ]
and does all this outlandish stuff and
in the end like everyone clamors for
impeachment but are we any closer to
that so like I hope this is a little
this is a tangible crime yeah yeah it is
you're right hi special ed and I and I I
hear you because it's like dude needs to
understand that there consequences like
he's so off the hinge he's so like
diluted with
this power and fame he absolutely off
the chain he's doing anything is he is
the definition of doing anything yes
before the views he no no well I hate I
got a video on deck yeah I feel great
yeah I feel great and I'm not I'm not
Oh Austin dinner I'm gonna make a bunch
of money off his [ __ ] disco okay you
guys got a tab running yeah I want to
try the analog [ __ ] real quick that tell
ya guys it all over has that babe I love
it it's a it helps it's very family Hoss
and you know yeah I like that I mean
this episode's not brought to you by
this it looks like no a space tickets
very I like how slim it is because I
tried another one this is called a jewel
I used to have another ecig that was
like big fatties yeah I didn't feel like
a cigarette yeah yeah it was like flick
it like it okay that one belt in it
keeps me on the right side of hunger see
how it like thing got him up yeah yeah
i'ma looking at a couple of rats and
that's cool that's edgy level [ __ ] the
dead babes heart I'm on my way
that's higher let's do the new so roll
the roll the intro let's get into the
news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I probably should I should probably do
it so they don't hear it and I'm in a
[ __ ] truck is an interesting overhaul
in the new second alright here we got we
are officially in the new segment well
again take the lead alright guys so we
got some spicy ones this week first up I
don't anybody's heard about this but it
set a lofty goal in Baltimore we're
going for a let's go hey Audra now I'm
going to throw the video over there oh
you are okay
alright I'm [ __ ] a separate alright so
in Baltimore there is a call for a
murder free weekend yes this is one
let'em now no murder let's just say it
because people need to hear it No
right that'll work apparently we've seen
already 188 murders in Baltimore that's
here Wow go for a record there that it
and so I guess the solutions simple just
don't kill anybody I find that I wonder
if the hardened gangsters are like you
know what today's the day today's the
day I'm going to survive this [ __ ] yeah
they're right you guys you know what one
weekend just one so what is that a
murder free weekend robbery for just a
weekend and then it is Monday night I am
right back out to be blast murder on
Monday hurts my thank you an honor like
the they trying to keep the numb like
why this weekend it's actually in August
so uh
oh my god something like that so this is
gonna be [ __ ] murders so weird
that's uh and what was the committee
like who-who's no it's uh no it's not
actually his mother I think however kids
murdered okay okay there's there's a
real sentiment I absolutely absolutely
that makes it well will you all you guys
participate and then I pledge to
participate yeah I'm not going to I
don't know every single person that
weekend you get order elsewhere yeah
yeah I get that I do have a trip to
Juarez
oh well then go nuts we're doing a
Baltimore right
wait is that a real place yeah yeah
sounds real what American in August and
see how they did on the last good point
that's yeah let's down we'll have an
update then Mike is a little quiet they
say so was it you got a holdout Mike
real close okay oh right and always hard
my music yeah yeah Wow microphone
etiquette a thing Dan welcome to our
world day alright so next story there
was a light in your mouth there was a
crash there was a crash in Oregon we're
a bunch of shipping containers filled we
accidentally spilled looks like 7,500
pounds
well that may be needed this autoplay
should I hate that autoplay share the
worst YouTube ads or nothing okay you
know what I mean there's everything else
is an imitator and you scroll down a 500
pounds of slime eels well pour avoir the
owner version
oh my god guys these shipping containers
they crash and it actually crashed into
another car already even big you'll only
[ __ ] I've seen that anime yeah is that
food though yeah I guess so this is a
delicacy in Korea in China coming this
particular species espanol grows off of
the Oregon coast there oh my and when
they get freed out they secrete this
like mucus oh that's like eel jizz are
you telling me they got freaked out
they try to make a run for it but like a
defense mechanism it's supposed to like
yeah things like fish one is trying to
you wanted that you know about the
alleles yeah they're called they're not
actually eels they're actually hagfish
oh I am serious
they have a bunch of with wars running
alongside their body that secrete the
mucus
right they are older than dinosaurs wait
why living one of those is a number I've
seen videos of people eating them and I
was just like what [ __ ] Twitter like
they I don't know if they eat them in
the slide like crazy I'm sorry if I'm
running right is this some of you
planned oh no no that's not access
and it's an interesting creature oh
there was jizz all over the road and
also for that guy good guy that car that
image in the car is all the [ __ ] in it
well forever haunt my dream he was a you
came out like covered in swine they're
like oh you got here with the aw no
unrelated yeah he'll got me one came
right through the back of the truck any
idea honey
how many yields were spilled damn 7,500
no 7,500 pounds
oh yeah like God's Way more that is a
lot of demand for eel that is a that is
a absolute yes sorry I didn't apologize
no like you're right though like just a
trucks full of like I went two and a
half now I can't that's not right like
three tons and then some almost four
it's almost four tons of eels
I think the EPA heard that they've been
alive since the dinosaurs and we're like
well let's [ __ ] wipe them out yeah
yeah either right I'd take them excuse
we've only been around for a hundred
thousand years so let's uh nobody beats
us yeah number one baby number fill a
truck with a new let no an SUV yeah you
know I say [ __ ] that's my takeaway
from the story if they're not eating
them let them spill on the damn road yes
why not yeah absolutely how the hell'd
they become a delicacy not a delicate
about the creeps
well Asian is yeah which is why you know
what these guys look fun hey Dan yeah
it's always been challenges and this one
it's got to seem that they love us
better for there we go people find this
gross I found a way to heat it I don't
want just real I want to L with mucous
membrane sometimes the heels that energy
thank you
every animal justice but this animal is
the most fun thing that's the nickname
to the the hagfish and the jizya yes
yeah I'm sure we're coming back fish
come on my own as Virginia bill today
the Jersey oh my god we like to fill
trucks with them and that's right mommy
I'm going to try what I'm feeling
yes thank you all right what's next
alright next what so five four over in
China a new trend is these personal
defense weapons they call them an anti
permit anti pervert flamethrower
this basically straight up a lightsaber
oh hell yeah
not even oh [ __ ] show us that video look
at this show us yes wow it actually gets
way crazier penalty burns at like 7000
degrees Fahrenheit or something like
that so it could shoot up to like almost
a foot so for those you guys who are who
are listening and out watching it
actually looks like a like so it's
really right up torch I mean that is
like a three foot flame I've never seen
so I'm a little saddened that it had to
take perverts in China to create that
incredible technology because that's
amazing that's a cooling it under a
while necessity is the mother of
invention event they sure do they'd sure
do say that maybe was trying to grab
your slimy ol off your plate you hit
them with them yeah we'll just be a New
Jersey like they feel right everyone the
jizz saver
that's so yeah right we have an so
pervert is illegal in China Oh someone
is saying in the chat but it's on Amazon
currently no locks matter if it's on
Amazon I that's the last thing I want to
be seeing out like EDC is your new digit
spinners right here's your kid with a DD
now here you know he plays thinner
daddy's got to work and a kid loves fire
you have how many of these are been sold
people are actually watch walking around
these in China blasting perverts is that
big of a problem like what's going on in
China pervert well I noticed Li okay I'd
like I think I get it there's like the
overcrowding and trains and they're like
a they're gropers Larry let you know
guys like grow the ladies
whatever having a pepper spray I don't
need a button is raised is pepper spray
like a [ __ ] LED saber okay they were
incredible technology no go the person
here is if you use pepper spray on a
train you're going to [ __ ] everybody up
on the train so instead give them a
block give them a little faster
well warning tomorrow will trigger
bottom or I get that yeah that looks
like it would go right through somebody
like a website I don't know I do dance
Mike can you hear it out there I know
more about it you definitely buying
things you sell more holes it is the
pollution overpopulation burn them all
Syria I'm just again I can't is just
such a weight like crazy cool technology
but what is strange like very specific
origin its perverts in China as opposed
to like for example like military
technology or like laser cutting or
something no not just perverts in an
overcrowded China like like that what a
weird necessity I mean that's not weird
the wrong word I mean it's tragic and
it's shitty know it but it's just very
not what you'd expect
I don't know with that in a couple -
Jake Paul a couple of posts Mullaly burn
that house their clothes alone these
days it was got him like memory no just
[ __ ] hand three kopeck O'Connell I
just got really [ __ ] cool we need to
market these as anti Jake Paul divided
he will come to your out and he shows up
your house came up gimmick to don't buy
his merch the entire dollars seriously
honestly I was not the band type Polar's
all right Paul alright that's pretty
fascinating they did what else we got
Dan then this was a little little
lighter than yields are flamethrowers um
you guys remember boaty mcboatface know
I know this one
what obvious update I don't know so it's
super so a few years ago in the UK they
had a vote for this research vessel what
they were going to call it and they kind
of opened it to the public which is
always a great idea always always a
really good idea yeah I was like as I'm
out to do yeah and of course
boaty mcboatface ended up being the
winner and it was this big controversy
and then the government was like no
we're not going to do that and there was
uproar
everyone was like [ __ ] that it won so be
fair right and so I think they made some
compromise like the the sub like that's
on the boat is boaty mcboatface okay
okay so they've sort of got it through
so in
Sweden I believe yeah something similar
happened they did a vote and training
train phase and go ahead it listen to
some of the other names here but they're
they're honoring it this time apparently
they're going to honor it Sweden is a
great country they're very socialist
they are honoured yeah they don't get
jokes too well either they think that
that's an actual name like oh it is yes
it is
train in Israel good well listen to
these other operations other than
straight active so look at Karen Dylan
babies go to green it was between
training ik train base or Hakan Miriam
or Poseidon right that was when I
remember how very imperious oh yeah yeah
exactly exactly and then training McRae
thank God that's gonna way to have a
sense of humor like I got that like saw
those three options together I would
obviously vote for training McCain says
yeah oh this if this were a subreddit it
would be made me smile make you happy
but honestly I'm really high like when I
saw this on whatever like are not the
onion or whatever the [ __ ] this made me
really happy because I do remember Bodie
mcboatface in the uproar that has
surrounded it but I'd be happy that you
made you up didn't see there you go it's
contagious and frigerator died like two
oranges kills people
all right overall hot italian tell me
wala way to feel how I feel Prentiss is
cute right in the vision delica no
parentheses said not click face I was
out of training m'q trained face
transition over 6 3 I mean they could
have more options like Jake full army
the strongest would have been business
reveal good strong we are strong or we
are live have you been that way biddy
really waited not by his March he will
come to your house yeah find you and
make it public where you live have you
guys have you guys seen the tweet that
he retweeted well it's like that one of
his one of Jake balls fans said we are
lit we are savage we are Jake ball it's
it's amazing you should really know it's
only something like we are Jake
Pollard's we are savage we will bring
something like that so in here is it
sounds like a bad Nike ad it really does
we have anyway
let max hit us with the den they go next
up basically you know if you take this
whole jake paul thing to its logical
conclusion yes later you wind up without
our next story hold on I got this twin I
got this sweet he retweeted this we are
savages we are always lit we are
powerful we prank people we love team 10
we love bizarre bizarre Clark that's his
business show we are Jake Pollard's and
he retweeted that and here we also
retreated there's 8.5 million people who
would do anything to live next to Tim
10th house by the way there are 12 year
old girls like ok cool you do inking
Lenexa gig 10 being a [ __ ] adult who
owns a house idiot
I didn't realize you had a Disney show
oh yeah I take back everything I said
it's great yeah he's cool with me now
did me show yes see what else who helped
the party behind like a savage making
people is tow savage needs to be real
hard
he also retreated he ain't gonna listen
nobody he's going to flip intended dude
with the crying laughing I hate to
retweeted that I'm so cool not ironic
cuz it's the avatars a 12 year old girl
and then he tweeted himself I'm still
going to send it he's the first Disney
star to lose his mind before getting the
job on Disney that's right what's there
now he's on there he just plays a minor
is like a character in the show for the
kids
yeah for the kids any tweeted up crazy
how people care about me being a bad
neighbor bigger fish to fry and it's and
people are getting shot every day you
should worry about that that's not a
justification for your shitty behavior
Jake Paul you can't just hide behind a
statistic and be like oh people should
[ __ ] worry about that instead Oh
that meant that tweet made me so mad
which I know is what he wants but I
don't really care if somebody does my
shot somewhere can we please go figure
that out well not in Detroit in a couple
weeks right
the Baltimore Baltimore Morgan for bad
timing th so just write five I know it's
like awful you know like murder away
another still making whatever happens in
Detroit stays Detroit Baltimore no
murdering one weekend Ohio area as if
people can't worry about two things at
one time
exactly exactly yo man yeah maybe I am a
shitty neighbor slash person but people
are dying you know if I already world
yeah what's another drink
oh I'm still drinking I think another
bud you want yeah and I'm slowing down
now I'm actually pretty drunk I'm pretty
Tozer huh here's the damn guy you got
ass is what I'm empty all right Cheers
it's not it's only bad luck even
something you got absolutely yeah don't
get too much Hennessy in you because I'm
gonna have a beer I think you know that
raw gimme y'all I'm sorry is saying the
coin watch is just a drunk at all so
what's a beer I have a beer I'll be
right back
this is great you know just hanging out
yeah with microphones interfaces
capturing all of our perps and public
for the world is yeah absolutely just
shooting the [ __ ] though my stomach is
alright next story the next story is
kind of happy that it is next door is
heavy very heavy duty I don't know if
you guys heard about this a actually
really good investigative report from
BuzzFeed seriously apparently they they
become a hard little and good news yeah
yeah cattle reporters I actually read
this whole article and it's a really
good article right you might be pretty
disturbed by this I want only like it
was people soup - yeah yeah it was
really disturbing so it already has a
sex called
I thought he hit him right dystrophy
sorry yeah so apparently he he has a
let's see up to six women living in his
house that he controls every aspect of
their life um records himself having sex
with them and distributes it to his
friends yeah oh my gosh
and he calls them my babies and he makes
them call him daddy I'm not creepy at
all maverick we're not creepy oh and a
doula once it was my god when he when he
started to like getting their
relationship with them what it does is
it gives them a new cellphone and then
they keep it sealed
yep what are they complaining about so
he says well let me tell you in this
economy they can only use it when he
allows it and to whom he allows it and
he tells them what to wear and what to
do like according to this article and
it's really there's a lot of evidence
like there's a lot okay here's Mike not
just one rumor
are they complicit are they willing
participants so that's the problem with
it it's it's pretty much it's like a
cult a manipulator my team that's is
that this thing that's actually a little
second and that's why yeah
he's gotten caught on a time thing wait
safe Daniel are you Talia we active teen
right yeah in 1994 there was a follow-up
article from Rolling Stone and they kind
of broke down his whole history of this
kind of behavior and yeah he was 27 at
the time and he married alia well at 15
15 at the time when they were making
their album this is not a joke
age ain't nothing but a number yeah and
that actually oh no no that was so that
that's I think that's why I got so six
on this story because I was a big ugly
offense and I remember this album and
all of a sudden like everything has a
completely different context yeah yeah
ages the age is not nothing but a number
at a certain point yeah yeah unless it's
illegal
yeah you know look okay Allah outside
but it puts a lot of side let's put
statuary rape aside
yeah if you're fifty old was she
christened if you're a 15 year old girl
think back to when you were 15 years old
you didn't [ __ ] know what was good
for you I was married I live year old
actually is that right yeah I've [ __ ]
up JJ I would wake up young seriously if
you're 15 how old was he at the time 27
like that's you cannot you're just not
there emotionally maturely you're a
[ __ ] kid you're watching Looney Tunes
also he actually he was assigned he was
assigned to be like her producer so she
was like up-and-coming new artists and I
think her uncle was like his manager or
something like that so we put them
together and it was like we're gonna
work on your album together and so also
you got to put that in context for her
it's like the guy who's making her
possible for a career yeah so there's
this kind of coercion subtle coercion
nice so subtle even and it's the same
thing with the Gulf that is keeping in
his cult right there at all of them were
aspiring singers yeah
so that picked them up here that's no
way I can make you famous yeah there's
something I don't know if I'm bringing
this up from something else but isn't
there something in this article about
how he would film having sex with yeah
show them to people yeah yeah he'd have
buddies over be like yeah you want to
see me having sex
yeah with a 19 year old but but here's
the flip side to that he makes them all
dress in track suits and they're not
allowed to look any of his male friends
in the eye what yeah I want any of them
to like lust after them or what a buck
would go to that house guys I
investigate the Russian occupation
directory that's already like right
there you know I'm going to going out
with our Kelly welcome like ten girls
and tracksuits won't look mean I look at
the wall they try Putin's behind this
Blair Witch yeah Stan paste the wall
yeah yeah it's earlier in the I look at
later which is a [ __ ] started sodomized
field so the parents of all these girls
are like they're trying to report it to
the police but apparently because the
girls are there like from their own will
right the police can't do anything
because the problem would call that's
the cult
yeah the special Motorola phones the
can't dial nine one Wow so our Kelly I
mean going back to but this is a really
circular episode cuz we were talking
about how team ten plugs I know that's
why I was saying this is Theresa yeah
but II think I'll tell is one of the ten
he's in this the 10 spot 100 why don't
you guys are making URLs in it he's the
silent guys are doing we have some
late-breaking news
oh it is being spamed right oh boy what
not um firmed but Jake Paul looks like
he's being evicted and faked there's a
video I guess really that's what [ __ ]
happened I think me and our tweeted this
they don't know if it's a prank or not
here let me throw it on the screen I
call it fake news breaking there's
alright let's see can you look at
thought oh well this is probably a prank
well by the way team 10 I'll get that
nobody can evict him can you turn it up
turn it up a little bit right crank it
or [ __ ] just post Malone sending him a
lightsaber
oh yeah I don't know about that creepy
that's I don't know if this house I
think I listen how many people are out
there yeah creepy that they're just
there at all time that has a [ __ ] hey
on the side of his door I like right of
a horse one yeah this is first off also
he doesn't get it is that lunch going
there's a basically how old you let's
order to me is a your okay coming up so
yeah apparently take that I'm fiction
owes to the door like Martin Luther
Martin Luther during the Christian
Reformation right oh wow nice wrap I
don't know why I hear them on right now
we've been full of visitors a great
educational nailing oh yeah yeah Wow
under the eight-year-old kid come out
take a photo
I don't the thing is that they in
probably sketch they made a prank where
they like a police guy came to arrest
him and that was a prank so that's why I
don't know if this is real
oh yeah know always doubt it I mean I'm
just more than the eviction I'm just
really alarmed of the constant circus of
children out in Italian yeah this is so
[ __ ] creepy like have we saw anything
like that before like you know you think
about like Leonardo DiCaprio and all
these like the the bad boys of Hollywood
and everything like is is there any
comparison between this and the question
like setting a pool on fire
yeah maybe Leo Caprio when he was in the
liquidity posse or whatever is a rock
star
if you look back at these uh rum
rambunctious rock stars who attracts
hotel rooms yeah I'm fancies yeah that's
what you hear about every buck and [ __ ]
up right except his fans aren't like
teenage to twenty year old girls right
his fans are actually eight-year-old
children twelve year olds and the star
is just a vlogger like what is the right
news not in Titanic is not efficient and
he didn't make ours and their vinyl
whatever might you're like what is you
bite your foot Eric get out I said have
you not heard his mileage oh yeah I
didn't might I got a little Hennessy in
me yeah you know I know y'all to the mic
you're going to kill our viewers this is
a we have a pitch limiter right no no as
soon as you're doing
I'm sorry to everyone when I drama you
want for me you expect better for me
drunk Hennessy bottle is about only a
quarter left this is what you watch for
that's right such as it's episode as
default go to NASCAR to see the car
crashes that's kind of what happened
here today a free podcast yeah see the
paula fresh okay back to our Kelly yeah
there's a video that TMZ did with the
one of the girls and they're like so is
everything okay with you and she's like
yeah I don't know why is everyone
overreacting everything is okay and she
obviously looks so uncomfortable we saw
that oh yeah yeah then has it and then
there's a part where they ask her can
you tell us where you are and you can
see a shadow of someone saying no like
you can see their hand shaking no whoa
yeah I've got to pull that up by the way
I heard that in Jake Paul's video he
does show postpones license plate mm-hmm
nice guy anyway that's not cool cool guy
what a jerk yeah not cool you guys think
Arco is a spirit cooking I know I've
heard about that what's that it's
possible is that it's like baby blood
that keeps you young or so in that
Hillary was feeling like I thank you I
think you need to be a politician to
yeah you got to be you got to be going
to Bilderberg meetings okay no one's
here cooking it's our Kelly
he's like doing live concerts at
Bohemian Grove is on you yes I do
trip tip tip all right I love it I love
it
Karthik alright this is a TMZ video be
careful on the audio level and I just
mainly want to say that I am a heavy
place with my life and I'm not being
brainwashed or anything like that
oh really to a point where it definitely
has got a penis so you know I just
wanted to know my parents and everybody
in the world it I totally hi parents
well you don't okay no she doesn't
okay you're fine mhm you you are not
being ollie
to your will or doing anything that you
do not want to do oh no not at all never
been filming hostage or anything like
that in nature together so why is it now
that your family is coming forward and
saying this and they've asked for a
welfare check and everything like that
why do you say like oh like a check of
welfare okay and on and off about it six
five months I haven't really spoken
Svensson of everything they've been
causing problems in my life without a
nugget hostage and they inhale yes I
wheel and stuff like that because it has
I'm very hard work you know what's going
on with the situation because it is
neutral point where it's getting too
much out of hand you know we have to
deal with it in me being 22 it's just
you know it's just not right
so I haven't spoken to them mainly in
about five or six months
really oh I mean they'll you know take
like classical yep cut my parents off
they take their phone are you angry in
Georgia or where are you I know you can
Wow yeah I know yeah I know I find when
I was on the move yeah when I was
watching on my phone it's even more
clear you can see on her shirt like yeah
the shadowkhan so creepy you know that's
so sad in creepy oh yeah we're fine I
haven't talked to my parents for six
months and I can't tell you where I'm
located what's what Scientology where
they have um a [ __ ] what's the acronym
it's like you cut someone off
suppressive person yes MP thank you so
much exactly yeah same [ __ ] thing
same [ __ ] yeah what the hell Kelly
also the really sad thing is that they
all like aspire to be musicians and then
in a few of the stories it was a girl
who went to show probably wasn't like
the front row you know and then he was
like you come backstage afterwards and
then she would go with her parents
yeah with reparent with the parents and
the parents are like cool is interested
she's talented maybe or maybe can coach
her and then invites her to a show she
goes the prank gets a little weird
you know and then invites her to travel
with him and then she doesn't tell the
parents because she's like I'm going to
travel with the superstar is going to
make me a star the parents don't know
about it and then they lose constantly
and she's too late exactly and that's
what happened but a few of them it's
crazy
oh it's so sad and creepy and scary and
weird that this [ __ ] happens
I know I sound like John Oliver Kurt its
current year it's what he's ever seen at
the same time if you know it is [ __ ]
weird that like doesn't it seem like
dated to talk about Colts just in
general yeah that Colts man [ __ ] dumb
yeah still goes on today depends how
much money they have true he's like a
master manipulator
yeah exactly he's back in the day and
there's so many cases of girls who like
sued him and then they came to an
agreement and he paid them so there is
no yeah so there's no like actual like
he was guilty of that or guilty no cause
you're broad singer but there's like a
million shots weird one to so many
stories it's crazy [ __ ] article email
what's the R stand for wow thank you and
thank you this is why the people tune in
if this is named like Robert or Richard
or grape either he's a [ __ ] same
yelling he's a human slime eel really
continue washing ideas wait worms did
with the finger wagging I think it was
startled by modulus title it's very sad
oh yeah alright let's move it on this
looks like laughter but I side you'll
excuse us I'd I believe that is what
else we got uh I think this last one
actually so I'm sure everybody's heard
about this is all over the news but OJ's
back baby
oh yeah well the world is a more
interesting place with Jose even though
he's murdered people I hope people still
have his [ __ ] so he can go steal it
again and come on right down the [ __ ]
personality and then how what must take
some very three more years all right now
for an hour right time to get my [ __ ]
back okay so Oh Jay Simpson after
basically admitting to murdering Nicole
Simpson and what was her her lover's
name did it admit it I mean he wrote a
book if I
hiatus or do funniest was hypothetically
about if I did it which is pretty much
it I did here's how I do it in the in
the publish Liars out it never actually
has the murder in it well they never
published it every lack lash really they
were going to publish this book called
if I did it and then after all this
public backlash like what the [ __ ] are
you doing yeah to my all the shirt they
have canceled the book thank god they
desperate for money because he actually
lost in a civil suit because he got
acquitted criminally but then Nicole
Brown's family wife sued him civilly for
her murder
and he was found guilty in that one so
the guy is so weird and milk drive
pretty much all of his assets
did you see the ESPN like three-part
documentary series no it's awesome
I like six hours long and we said then
then that's like this recent one yet the
briber Thursday's but I think that's
what I meant wait one I'm not talking
about that the fictionalized the not the
Ryan Murphy one I'm talking about like
the what you guys may be talking about
with John Travolta oh that's the yeah
that's Ramat eyes what's that it was it
was a reenact yeah yeah that's a great
one I have that and then I watched like
actually I think it was ESPN they made
like an animal that one like follows his
early career it does but it's very even
more even more so than the Ryan Murphy
one it's very very in-depth like from
early on shows why he was such a big
deal it's fascinating because it's just
so it's so bizarre especially when he
gets to Florida this is after he's you
know he's been found not guilty and he
lives like this weird second life in
Florida and he just parties it up and he
like films a pilot for a [ __ ] Punk'd
ripoff but it's like all it it's all
about n I you know I know you don't use
[ __ ] you I have oh its legend its
legendary he like you know he drives a
white Bronco it covered in blood them -
AB - - yeah what for reactions yep I'm a
guy that really sounds like a [ __ ]
joke I mean it sounds like a weird like
bad like monologue oil voce is
fascinating he was on top of the world
he was one of the most famous NFL
players of the movie star and he just
murdered yes I was listening they were
talking about it today on Howard Stern
Show and they were talking about how
young people like maybe our age but a
little younger like in their 20s don't
even know him for how big it was their
only know him for the murder face right
and they're and they're asking like is
he really as big as people say and they
say no he was he was actually really fun
all my acting you had a lot of cultural
phenomena your time that murder happen
it was so big he was he was like super
one of the most famous people in America
yeah I was I was going to say he's out
[ __ ] killing six boy so anyway he
murdered his wife right no well she
wasn't now she's dead they really really
got separated or something was she oh
yeah yeah they were separately I'm but
here's here's my question to you guys do
you think Jimmy Fallon's going to get
them on like I think that joke tweet I
know that's bad press I think it's I
don't think it's out of the realm of
possibility that sick I don't think that
guy deserves and Jimmy would just be the
entire time like calm and ease no crazy
don't worry don't worry disorder looks
like I was going to be the whole package
is power I know you crazy
haha though that's a pretty good don't
manage not know I think I think he's
smarter because he's more particular
with image good I saw a girl Rogan quit
should I have what a Joe so Joe Rogan is
more interesting angle because it's more
conversation based than Joe Rogan VA and
on him he's not afraid of anything
he said should I have Oh Jay or not I
would say yeah absolutely
we're here with I was able to say about
Shore a spirit molecule and DMT and the
Enlightenment of the human mind
yeah absolutely I like Joe Rogan
believes in Joe Rogan all got again
yeah the observations are short yeah the
only thing I've been deprived of is
sunlight so if you guys don't know the
story of audiences fascinate because he
he basically got acquitted of murder and
then he went to Las Vegas and did a an
armed robbery of his memorabilia and
that's what he's in prison for now right
well not the video of that anymore
[ __ ] hilarious by the way cuz like he
goes in there with a mask on and he's
like give me back my [ __ ] and the guy
and there's like oh gee
is that you what like no man
maybe much you like do you know me yes
guys [ __ ] back know how possession works
let's go my girl [ __ ] anymore it's like
a bad judge every case that is I need to
just I want to point out based on what
you just said in his uh parole hearing
you know he was explaining his behavior
and apologizing and everything and he
said I'm sorry that things turned out
the way they did
classic non-apology sure right I had no
intent to commit a crime
oh so he went in with the ski mask and a
gun it's not it's not a crime yeah this
night II did not tend to yeah that's
nicely first yeah it wasn't my intention
every was armed right yeah armed robbery
and a ski mask
yeah but crying is it cause I don't
think he had a gun but I think this
people oh okay okay okay and he's like
yo you take the gun you got a bright one
he's gonna launch it the guy hey you
could do some damage with that book yeah
you know in its heyday Oh Jay I've seen
I've seen your arm man I know you could
hurt me with that cannon I'm not Oh Jay
average guy was a football with the same
build six and voice also Jay here's my
face not Oh Jay all right then it's it
anything that's it Oh dream on
definitely I caught up I'm thankful for
lovers aren't you well this is a pretty
[ __ ] spicy wild ride of an episode
everyone okay guys I guess that's it we
can probably wrap it now yeah well you
guys have work to do
you guys got to get into the lab yeah go
home I ain't going to trunk back get
back cringe mat suit back well that does
a sink back in the day in the early days
of this podcast we'd have to go edit it
but now the live now so that's what you
made a blog they put up tomorrow XL
video alright well thank you guys Jack
thank you Eric thank you so much check
out their YouTube yeah maybe it's a
gription yeah make sure to check out
their tone guys are the best
this was hilariously awesome wish you
guys a call back on some time with that
yeah let us you know I'm name the time
and place
we will find out how we don't do [ __ ]
[ __ ] true that's positive last very
much the glorified way of hanging out
yeah I'm all for that I don't get out of
my house all I do is that it's oh yes
please Oh cold Anne happy birthday
thanks for doing all right then then
great job on the news I will be a
recurring segment I hope you guys
enjoyed it thanks for tuning in thanks
for watching everybody we appreciate you
and we'll see you next Friday so god
bless you appreciate you Papa bless you
Papa blessed Jake Paul's strongest army
on earth we are savage where your
lineage we never forget never forget
don't buy the nursery we'll find you
oh all right bye everline bye guys thank
you so much welcome everybody back to
the h3 podcast about to get into the
ghost stories but first let's take a
shot at any turn into Incan Allah time -
not anymore down it doubt your
consumption we'll just use that as your
shoutout yeah so we're going to get into
ghost stories because that's just a
staple of the show here it's a tradition
there's nothing better than a ghost
story oh no son I'm bored cheers to
spooks and goofs this pretty good and
then that it's been such a joy having
you guys are the best man I love you
guys this right back at you buddies love
in this room and it makes me so happy oh
this is fantastic Lance really is I'm
like you know Jack and I are old old
collab buddy
we really are man I'm speaking up we got
to do some more [ __ ] yeah I'm just
laying let me know if there's any make
flags
oh there's much more flights under when
I thought okay so one is a good one yeah
so this is the segment of the show where
we talk about ghosts which is a weird
little segment we do because I'm a very
skeptical person as as hila I don't
really believe in ghosts but the whole
idea of the super national theme super
national supernatural thing that
fascinates me because it seems like
everybody has an interesting ghost story
so with that being said do you guys have
any of those stories or supernatural
supernatural anything as much as I like
to listen to them I still haven't seen
much evidence that ghosts exist I had
one experience in
one of my friends houses and I was super
drunk during in which I feel like most
ghost stories I send after our super
drunk oh yeah drunk as [ __ ] and I was on
the toilet right and as I was all did
ghost story right of course because the
ghost want to know what you're doing
there like I miss I miss doing that and
like the whole night they've been
talking about ghost stories in that
house and really I was like had in my
head I was like I really want to know if
ghosts are real so I'm on the toilet um
I got nothing else to do
are there any ghosts here I'm like
actually talking out loud oh my god any
ghosts in this house if you if there are
please do something I'm not I'm
intrigued by the fact that on the John
you had yeah I don't know I was alone
like I was like no one's ever gonna know
about this oh it's not about those
randomly yeah well it was an old house
and they were like yeah we have ghosts
here and they were telling their
hilarious okay okay told me this [ __ ] is
haunting and I was like I want to see a
ghost and they're like well just you
know stick around for a while you might
see one or you might see something
creepy so I'm on the toilet and I'm like
then it goes here if there's a ghost
here just do something and a paper towel
roll on the on the sink counter rolled a
little bit I was like cool ghost haha
now in my mind thinking back and that
was obviously just a breeze coming in
through the window oh my that's moving
it well I'm like asking into the
nothing Neela's we either wants to
believe in the supernatural now that how
how would you breath move the doll I
don't know and I like a window it I
think a window or something like that
but I saw it's the stupidest ghost story
ever like how do you know the grocery oh
well want to move the paper towel wrong
well they hit it and I say God I need
the fantastic story like I freaked out
though like I ran that in the room there
rails a guy's girl paper towel rolls
myself ghost is like because we want
ghost hunting with post Malone ones and
I'm like and he kept being like ela
Ethan stop talking because we're not
gonna be able to hear the ghosts and I'm
like these [ __ ] ass [ __ ] the low
tier ghost burst of their [ __ ] boy yeah
every time what I would say it's like
it's that's that's the best you got
mmm you know remove the paper towel roll
like like I talked into the beyond I I
spoke my words in tonight's another
generation of reality of an afterlife
and what they had in response was they
made a paper towel roll go but I'm going
but like I think on their side they're
probably like channeling it that's
[ __ ] that's a pretty good story about
being on it it makes me it didn't answer
anything yeah and I felt really
embarrassed about getting so worked up
about it
in the immediate moments after cuz again
I was pretty blasted I ran like ten of
my friends who I immediately embarrass
myself a friend by being like girls ever
but go through the paper towel roll guys
go surreal they're like ah right I know
what we're talking about they just lay
this on it we stay here like shield
babies crying yeah yeah there's doors
there's chains being dragged on figuring
out one sheet out of dude it seems like
it's always like you either you can find
an explanation for it
or you got a want to believe yeah and
then you like you have to make a well
say that so to explain having ghost
hunted with Austin who is a believer
that you it definitely requires a leaf
or as I've observed and suspension of
disability yeah sure
it's fun although don't worry I didn't
learn noses and then before we left but
I feel like they more you have to ask
yourself we wouldn't go something we
heard some really weird noises that
spooked us all we have to ask yourself
what's more likely a lizard or a snake
kind of creature or a bottles ghost is
the béchamel shouting it it's like what
really there's a better explanation
after you have any ghost stories I'm so
boring I don't because I was just
racking my brain the entire time and
trying to thank you I heard and I really
don't there's nothing I like going just
back my little history of time anything
creepy and unexplainable I mean I walk
into a room full of ectoplasm ones but I
don't think that could be anything dude
yeah yeah that could have just been a
bunch of slimy old hag fish so I real
sorry sure real hey what's on
Nickelodeon it was a Nickelodeon I
should did you got slimed
oh man member laughs it's fun to think
that ghosts are real you know it really
gives us hope I like to believe like if
I get hit by a bus tomorrow I would love
to be a ghost and just I'm done ohana
you love do ya
yeah Oh somebody's got a hot tub I wanna
have like a like a ghost you know like
Patrick Swayze absolutely I have to get
into Potter he's gonna try to move on
and I'm just going to honor a new life
and [ __ ] I'm just going to ruin that
contest on your own my one of them I can
keep swinging around nothing there's a
towel I'll tell you this I have a
non-believer but I would love to believe
in the idea of an afterlife like I mean
I haven't specifically I don't think
it's real but I mean like it's just it's
enticing you know I was I was born and
raised Catholic and at some point around
like are you religious no no some I just
kind of kind of just stopped I kind of
questioned everything there's a point in
time where I just started questioning
did you go to church as a young bush or
every Sunday and sometimes Sunday and
Tuesday twice a week I went to a
Catholic middle school just to eighth
grade and yeah and I was super I prayed
every night I was very religious when
I'm prayed like well we
prayers like Oh silly concerns please
make my exam yeah yeah yeah help me help
me study better you know you never
prayed for something to happen you
prayed for the strength to make it
happen I did that a lot so instead of
like I please let me be this trick to
deal with this exactly like help me like
don't feel me an A+ on this test
tomorrow give me the strength to study
harder get the A+ that's what I was told
I still I like that bit of an anthem is
I could put good energy on there and
absolutely that I don't just as a
relative doing it will give you the
strength to persevere at what age did
you start questioning 18 I you know I uh
this out got ready to [ __ ] you know like
you know and I'll tell you what happened
this is so dumb it wasn't until 18 I
read Dan Brown's The Da Vinci Code that
just got rocked my [ __ ] world right
there and that's like it's so stupid cuz
it just like this pulp novel you know
and it's just it's like the chapters are
three pages each in there a hundred
chapters one of those like every chapter
is a cliffhanger but honestly like just
the the cliff notes and just all the the
research that went into it like I just
that was the point where cuz up till
then I never questioned anything and I
was very religious very religious my a o
L screen name in high school was
uncorrupted 630 no 630 and it wasn't
ironic like that's my birthday June 30
okay no I'm June 25th Oh Chad did not
matter hey whatever then yeah I hate it
that's our birth sign cancer you know
yeah it's such a terrible sign of cancer
yeah what cancer as a sign existed
before the thing right my the [ __ ] they
call it that when I call it like death
disease I might write a catchy name I
sign it
death by 50 she's not a catchy name but
yeah like I that's one would it for
whatever reasons that book and also the
other one angels and demons that that
just kind of like made me question my
face and made me ask myself questions I
never asked before I just kind of always
believed you know but I mean like that's
the personal thing I never wanted I
don't want
like press down on people because it's
like it works for me it doesn't work for
it I like religion you know we did
whatever you want to believe if it works
for you [ __ ] do it you know and that
worked for me but I did personally I
never experienced a encounter and I'm
lighter than my Braille God in some way
went during your religious a great
question um nothing specific comes to
mind and you feel like like it's really
superstitious this stuff the guys name
yeah cuz I used to be I used to be put
in like yeah when how about you when did
you start when I met this guy you ruined
every day teacher I was very into the
righteous I was 19 I know but it's
around the same age so yeah funny how
that I just said you were dogs bows yeah
yeah yeah and tell you bet beautiful
interesting it kind of all done
everything like clicks like a delicious
sure so I [ __ ] every look I woke my my
name like I'm not saying like you if you
believe in got your [ __ ] idiot like
no I am NOT like that it works for me
and but I mean like did the dude maybe
like what do I know I mean my parent or
does exist and I would love to be proved
wrong I would love to be mean that like
that's not a challenge like I want to
believe in I haven't I just I don't but
I really like just the notion of heaven
you know and I everyone describes their
own versions of heaven and like what a
lovely thing that could be it just I
don't think it's real but like I'm not
going to rub it in someone's face and be
like you believe in God that's cute you
know like that looking [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that move for people to know I know and
I hate be like oh you believe in God
well you're an idiot
well she's I hate that at low level yeah
it is very very low my mom my mom is
still like she believes in everything
but whenever you talk to her about it
the what she sees in it is just good
morals and and that that is just dying
or for anyone
human decency yeah or morals absolutely
like the bite like if nothing else the
Bible has some great life lessons and it
doesn't it has really a double shitty
once and don't you forget it so so like
yeah your mom is a great person but she
doesn't oh yeah she focuses on the good
lessons like you know be good to others
he'll know
everyone says your phone is God you know
what everybody's got their own version
of 100% some people are like oh god
hates gay people yeah and like gay
people are like well I mean I go to
church and my god doesn't right exactly
gay people that's really about my so how
does different about every you know
friend I mean God is there mind of the
man we create I'm in in my opinion we
created a greater God all the other way
around so I'm like yeah and it still
works even in like we created this kind
of idea this very extract idea of this
person who is situational who you know
validates what we want to believe that's
what it's but I love that it's
validation it's validation for all of
our like drives and goals it's like that
you know it's and sometimes it's
justification to I mean our minds are
not equipped to deal with the infinity
possibility down the university Oh when
we talk about God is just kind of we may
be addressing that yeah we individual
fire and we were like who's responsible
for this right yeah right now why does
fire exist right we didn't invent fire
by the way I don't mean that no no we
never get caught up that I'm and me but
I get it but it's true well we learn to
you know utilize it Rachel we were like
what where does lightning come from
where menacingly imagine Apes running
around little night and I mean it's a
[ __ ] we really somebody up there
sending yell do eyes right right right
horn Eidos or hurricanes or lightning
how did you know in fact then that it
was from a higher power course that's
the logical explanation what l would
like we heard there's a big one of us up
there exactly controlling every I get it
you know
there's there's like you know the idea
of like a sentient universe I think is
like a really good like play it safe
kind of version I'm thinking about it
we're like you can go up and like say
something to the sky but really you're
just like talking to yourself in a way
yeah favorite expression of that is what
Carl Sagan said which is my favorite he
says he humanity is a way for the
universe to know itself Wow we're like
the conscious mind of the universe
because we have this notion of
self-awareness and observation and
trying to use thanks to understand the
world around us so it's not so much that
got like in a way we are that God
because we have the ability to
look in on the universe and understand
it so without that intellect the
universe would just be a [ __ ]
mechanical it's just a clock that's
turning its gears but there's needed
mansion forever that's all right there's
no way to be like this to a even
acknowledge existence itself yeah if we
ever meet like an alien race you know
what [ __ ] God do they believe in
right
do you think they'll be crazy lien race
and they had the same copy of the Bible
is us then I thought alarm San Jose I
would probably be like you know what I
guess whoa hang on it is a ballgame yeah
yeah he told it how to make spaceships
all we had to do is not crucify him ha
ha ha but would it be win a big church
or synagogue distinction really really
is it finish it the Jews all decisions
did it first but everyone else is a
tester there's always some salacious
[ __ ] right it's all the same guy at the
end game you fail there are some kids at
all today so high why
let's see you I [ __ ] you that's an idiot
you know they were they were Disney
before that Disney Channel five news
every day bro never done before oh and
when I'm doing well right now oh yeah we
really wrap it up Wow now we don't share
Harry Greg you Ethan they gave you on it
this was all of them thank you I come in
yo yo come here thank you guys for
joining us freaking watch live at twitch
calm not twitch calm they did again
widget on TV / HP products you can watch
every Friday at 3 p.m.
thanks for joining us thank you to these
two wonderful gentlemen and yellow and
course and we'll see you next week guys
thanks for tuning in appreciate
sometimes got it